bonjour bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver sur public sénat comme chaque
semaine on est au rendez-vous de
l'événement phare au sénat les questions
au gouvernement
dans une heure à 15 heures les sénateurs
vont questionner interpellé les
ministres on va tout vous expliquer tout
décrypter avec cette semaine encore
notre équipe de journalistes avec ti
jourdain à quai dans l'hémicycle du
sénat
alors steve de quoi on va parler cet
après midi et si on parlait qu'ovide tam
covin avec plein d'angles différents et
sur la question d'un éventuel report
d'un nouveau report des élections
départementales et régionales prévues et
bien en juin prochain il sera question
aussi de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire dans les écoles ou encore du
sort des petits commerces ou mis un
nouveau confinement
le gouvernement va être chahutée cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle c'est moi
qui vous le dit à tout à l'heure
steve avec nous et alexandre poussard
fidèle au poste salle des conférences
pour les interviews à chaud des
ministres des sénateurs quel est le
programme alexandre autres et bien comme
juste après la séance de questions
d'actualité vers 16h15 à peu près à je
serai avec bruno retailleau le patron
des sénateurs les républicains pour
parler des réunions mixtes interdite au
blanc organisé par le syndicat étudiant
unef
alors qu'une trentaine de sénateurs de
droite demandent la dissolution de ce
syndicat à tout à l'heure alexandre et
enfin comme chaque semaine on a le
plaisir d'être sur twitch avec le
streamer politique jour nassiet talus
jean étiez toujours avec ta communauté
et oui absolument hamon est là avec le
chat sur twitter en direct et on a hâte
de voir ce que les sénateurs et
sénatrices nous réserve comme question
pour le gouvernement cet après midi on a
hâte aussi à tout à l'heure dans une des
milliards notre face-à-face opposera max
brisson sénateurs l'est républicain à la
sénatrice communiste céline brulin tous
deux font partie de la commission de la
culture et de l'éducation
on va parler ensemble de l'école dans la
pandémie les protocoles sanitaires sont
ils à la hauteur faut-il vacciner
prioritairement les enseignants faut-il
fermer les écoles face à la pression
sanitaire qu'on en débat à 14h30
mais d'abord on va se pencher sur
l'inscription de l'environnement dans
l'article 1 de la constitution cette
mesure a été adoptée très largement à
l'assemblée la semaine dernière la
commission des lois du sénat débute ses
travaux sur le sujet cet après midi
d'ailleurs à 16h45
elle va auditionner le garde des sceaux
eric dupond-moretti ça sera à suivre en
direct sur notre antenne alors quelle va
être la position du sénat on voir
débattre avec quatre invités françoise
gatel bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice us et d'ille-et-vilaine membre
de la commission des lois également avec
nous ronan dantec bonjour bonjour
sénateur écologiste de la loire
atlantique vice président de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
et en visio qu'ovide oblige nous sommes
avec prisca thévenot vous êtes
porte-parole de la république en marche
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous pour ce
débat bonjour et a également avec nous
le constitutionnaliste bertrand mathieu
vous êtes professeur à l'école de droit
de la sorbonne et vous avez d'ailleurs
été auditionné ce matin par la
commission des lois avec d'autres
professeurs des doigts de droit sur la
réforme constitutionnelle voulue par
emmanuel macron réformes qu'il veut
faire adopter par le parlement avant
l'organisation d'un référendum la
majorité sénatoriale est pour l'instant
réticente fabien becker c'est l'une des
mesures emblématiques proposé par la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
soumettre à référendum
l'inscription à l'article 1er de la
constitution que la france garantit la
préservation de la biodiversité de
l'environnement et la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
alors qu'un projet de loi
constitutionnelle en ce sens vient
d'être largement adopté à l'assemblée
le sujet divise juristes et politique le
constitutionnaliste dominique rousseau
jugent la mesure inutile sur le plan
juridique il ya déjà la charte dans de
l'environnement qui a valeur
constitutionnelle c'est à dire une
valeur supérieure à la loi et qui
prévoit déjà le respect de la
biodiversité de l'environnement est là
contre le réchauffement climatique le
conseil constitutionnel a d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises fait prévaloir le le
respect de l'environnement par exemple
sur la liberté d'entreprendre
dans la foulée des députés l air la
droite sénatoriale apparaît hostile au
texte
gérard larcher ayant déjà fait savoir
qu'il privilégiait le terme
agir pour l'environnement plutôt que
celui de garantir
on peut s'interroger sur le fait que si
le fic la qualification de garantie
était en retenue elle puisse avoir à
terme par une interprétation du juge
constitutionnel un effet sur le
développement économique sur la liberté
individuelle fayat mnu multiples
questionnements qui se pose si nous
trouvons une rédaction qui nous paraît
beaucoup plus cohérente beaucoup plus
solide
à ce moment là nous la proposerons si
nous n'en trouvons pas parce que nous
pensons que les choses sont satisfaites
à cela on prendra une autre position
sénateurs et députés doivent pourtant
voté le texte dans les mêmes termes pour
ouvrir la voie à un référendum
au sénat le projet de loi sera examiné
courant mai alors on va commencer par
parler de cette bataille ce débat
sémantique qui agite les parlementaires
la version du texte votée par
l'assemblée stipule que la france
garantit la préservation de
l'environnement et de la diversité
biologique et lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique alors bertrand
mathieu on a entendu votre collègue
dominique rousseau dans le reportage
mais pour vous est ce que vous êtes
d'accord qu'est ce que vient pour vous
apporter cet article c'est ce qu'il
apporte quelque chose par rapport à la
charte de l'environnement de 2004 ou
bien ce qu'ils n'apportent rien on peut
poser la question plusieurs manières la
première question c'est est-ce que c'est
utile alors bien sûr on peut comprendre
que sur le plan emblématique
j'allais dire en un style à nouveau la
protection de l'environnement dans la
constitution mais je ferai observé ce
point de vue que cette protection figure
déjà dans le préambule de la
constitution de 1958 par renvoi à la
charte et même avec une force toute
particulière puisque ce texte du
préambule appui en fait le système
politique sur un trépied si je puis dire
d'une part les droits fondamentaux
d'autre part la source
des troisièmes piller la protection de
l'environnement mais on y reviendra
probablement tout à l'heure
indépendamment de la question de savoir
si cette d'ancrage ce nouvel ancrage
constitutionnel est nécessaire et ça
c'est une question essentiellement
politique
je reviendrai tout à l'heure si vous me
le permettez sur les problèmes
juridiques de cohérence et les risques
contentieux que peut porter cette
inscription pour vous il ya donc un
certain nombre de risques en tout cas la
droite préfère un terme moins fort que
garantir aujourd'hui le terme agir pour
l'instant écoutez d'ailleurs
l'argumentation du président du sénat
gérard larcher
est ce qu'il faut dire garantir la
protection de l'environnement et
inscrire sa constitution ce qui serait
extrêmement contraignants ou est-ce
qu'il faut dire simplement agir en
faveur de l'environnement ce qui serait
beaucoup plus accommodant nous allons
examiner de manière ouverte et positive
le texte qui va nous être proposées je
dis bien ouverte et positive
ça ne veut pas dire pour répondre qu'on
va dire garantie on va pas répondre aux
injonctions des uns et les autres mais
trouver le meilleur équilibre
françoise gatel vous que craignez-vous
avec le terme garantir certains à droite
estime que ça va pouvoir permettre une
explosion des contentieux est ce que
c'est votre cas je voudrais d'abord
rappeler à ceux qui nous regardent et
qui nous entendent de quoi on parle et
que nous ne sommes pas dans un débat
binaire où il y aurait d'un côté les
bienveillants à l'égard de
l'environnement et les malveillants qui
ne serait pas tracassé par ce sujet je
crois que chacun ici est conscient de la
nécessité de l'urgence d'agir
cela d'ailleurs n'est pas nouveau
puisque effectivement ça a été inscrit
dans la constitution et que si on a une
démarche de raison en disant l'objectif
c'est d'agir avec urgence pour
l'environnement on est tous d'accord sur
ce sujet est ce qu'il y a nécessité
d'inscrire quelque chose dans la
constitution c est ce que la
constitution ignore à faire abstraction
n'a pas pris en compte le respect de
l'environnement non il ya effectivement
une charte de l'environnement qui est
une valeur
suprême du du du credo constitutionnel
puisque il est à même hauteur que les
droits de l'homme
donc vous interrogez même sur le fait de
modifier la couleur moi je non non je
voyais la mort à nouveau il en fait je
veux d'abord dire parce que il ya une
sorte d'emballement médiatique qui fait
qu'on n'ose pas penser ou réfléchi je
veux d'abord dire et moi je respecte le
travail qui a été fait par la convention
citoyens mais qu'il n'y a pas rien il y
a des choses dont on doit dire qu'elles
ont montré leur efficacité puisque
effectivement on a trois décisions qui
ont montré que par exemple la liberté
d'entreprendre un moment était considéré
comme un droit qui pouvait être
inférieur quand c'est de liberté
d'entreprendre limitait les précautions
en matière d'environnement je pense par
exemple à la décision qui a été prise en
france de l'interdiction de produire de
vendre ou d'importer des produits
pharmaceutiques donc essayons d'abord
avant il ya les mots mais quel est
l'objectif que nous poursuivons et
vérifiant l'impact de tout ce que nous
faisons
ronan dantec cette réforme
constitutionnelle les écologistes la
soutiennent vous demander cette
inscription à l'article 1 de
l'environnement
on comprend qu'il ya déjà une mesure
symbolique mais est ce que pour vous ça
va vraiment avoir une utilité à ce que
les citoyens vont pouvoir se reposer
plus facilement des projets qu'il juge
contraire aux préoccupations
environnementales grâce à cela ah ben
moi je pense que la constitution elle
donne finalement c'est la boussole
elle donne le sens de l'action publique
et qu'est ce que dit le texte tel que la
convention citoyenne l'a proposé et on
peut se réjouir parce que c'est pas
souvent que au moins sur ce point le
gouvernement est suivie la convention
citoyenne c'est que en fait dans le
garantis et dans le lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
il y à cette idée forte et qui n'était
pas présente dans le débat politique
il ya encore quelques années qui est que
l'effondrement de la biodiversité
l'effondrement de
de la qualité de notre environnement est
évidemment le dérèglement climatique
menacent nos sociétés
donc dans le garantis il n'y a pas on
n'agit pas ce qu'on agisse à un terme
qui effectivement est tout sauf précis
parce que pour on peut agir sans
résultat on peut agir sans résultat pas
d'obligation
on peut toujours coupées 12 arbre est
planté 3 pâquerettes et dire on agit
mais ici ça veut bien dire qu'on se met
en situation de reconquête de la qualité
de l'environnement et c'est ça la
différence dans le dans le garantis et
effectivement et ça a été très
clairement dit par les interviews vous
venez de passer je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il y en a encore dans ce pays
une partie de la classe politique et
c'est la légitimité du débat politique
mais je ne partage pas évidemment cette
vision il y a des gens qui considèrent
que healy a d'abord une primauté de
l'économie qu'on fait de l'environnement
pour essayer de limiter les dégâts au
maximum mais qu'en aucun cas on organise
l'action publique pour avoir des
résultats et être en reconquête
et c'est là qu'est le débat et je pense
qu'effectivement le mettre dans la
constitution
ça n'est pas en droit constant par
rapport à l'achat s'est bien passé un
cran et mais de la société française en
situation d'assumer ses responsabilités
après ce cas tvh ne vous l'entendez vous
avez des alliés avec les écologistes eux
favorables et bien à la réception
mission au moins sur ce que j'allais
dire au moins sur cet article
alors qu'on a entendu également votre
tacle par rapport à ce que fait le
gouvernement des préconisations de la
convention citoyenne le projet de loi
climat en même temps il est examiné au
parlement est très critiqué pour sa
timidité alors est ce que on prend une
mesure avant tout leur du symbole et on
fait un petit peu moins haut niveau au
niveau des accès au nouveau au niveau de
ce texte
et bien malheureusement effectivement ce
qui est terrifiant plateau et je rendrai
ce qu'a dit madame la sénatrice gatel
c'est à dire que le sujet l'urgence
climatique n'a pas de culo litige nous
devons tous nous réunir dernier
cette problématique effectivement venir
discuter débattre sur comment le faire
au mieux et le faire au mieux donc pas
dans une démarche unity fhm et
d'accompagnement des français ensuite
oui je pense que le fait de l'inscrire
voir par rapport à son projet de loi
constitutionnelle dans la constitution à
l'article 1er c'est au delà du symbole
n'oublions pas que notre constitution
est le socle de notre république
donc il s'agit justement de permettre
cette cette rédaction et de le soumettre
à référendum
c'est bien de cela dont il est question
j'aurais géré par rapport au sujet de
sémantique garantir versus agir garantir
effectivement de l'obligation de
résultat dont il réagit à une obligation
de mou rien et là je trouve que ça
serait extrêmement timide
maintenant j'aimerais rappeler
effectivement parce que par rapport à ce
que viennent dire un monsieur le
sénateur c'est que l'action du
gouvernement pour l'urgence climatique
ne s'arrête pas à cette à ce projet de
constitution
et d'ailleurs on l'a vu des gars le plan
de relance 30 milliards investis pour
l'écologie mais également avec les lois
et les mesures faites avant avec les
galim par exemple la prime reno est en
ce moment le projet de loi climat
résilience qui vient justement permettre
une transformation structurelle des
modes de production des modes de
consommation et des modes de vie des
français au quotidien
le problème aussi bien de tout ce débat
aujourd'hui c'est que il ya un certain
nombre d'arrières pensées politiques qui
qui en fournissent le cadre est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cela ronan
dantec les écologistes vous allez voter
pour en même temps vous dénoncez on l'a
entendu le manque d'ambition du projet
de loi climat c'est c'est une position
un petit peu compliqué on est assez
simple parce que nous on a dit il faut
respecter ce qui est sorti des travaux
de la convention citoyenne
ça c'est un article est sorti des
travaux de la convention citoyenne donc
on le défend
al'inverse nous essaierons de restaurer
dans le passage de la loi au sénat
l'ambition des travaux de cette
convention qui ne se retrouvent pas dans
l'autre projet loi parce que peut-être
que les téléspectateurs ne savent pas
qu'il ya deux d'ailleurs deux projets de
loi le projet de loi constitutionnelle
qui va venir
le premier et après la loi climat elle
même beaucoup darty avec beaucoup de
mesure qui ne permettent pas il faut le
dire de respecter les engagements
internationaux de la france
tettey on est très loin des moins 55 %
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
2030 qui est pourtant la position de la
france défend à bruxelles françoise
gatel est ce que vous avez commencé par
sa part à dire y'a pas ceux qui sont
pour et ceux qui contre sont contre
l'environnement dans tout ce débat est
ce que la position de la droite elle est
quand même compliquée dans ce contexte
entre sa volonté de ne pas paraître
rétrograde sur les questions
environnementales et celle aussi de ne
pas donner une victoire politique à
emmanuel macron quelques mois de la
présidentielle parce qu'on sait ça va
être un débattra personnalisée notamment
et bien si la réforme est adoptée par le
parlement et donne lieu à un référendum
ce qui est bien l'objectif du président
de la république alors on peut pas
s'empêcher d'avoir des considérations
politiciennes en même temps me chauffe
que le sujet est autrement plus sérieux
que de là l'intérêt de l'aborder comme
ça voilà moi je suis considération les
exigences en même temps mais si on peut
un moment s'abstraire de sa prendre un
peu de hauteur est visé
la finalité qui est la nôtre et mettre
du bon sens hier qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une instrumentalisation c'est à dire on
n'arrive même pas à dire
peut-on raisonner sur ce dont il est
question c'est à dire en gros si vous
n'êtes pas pour le référendum vous êtes
contre l'environnement donc dans ces
maisons ici on a l'habitude de réfléchir
la convention citoyenne a fait son
travail
seulement j'aurais rappeler à mon
collègue que nous sommes aussi dans une
démocratie représentative et qu'il
appartient au parlement de voter sinon
faisons des conventions citoyenne
supprimant le parlement
voilà il faut aussi qu'on soit
responsable et qu'en même temps moi je
joue et je suis très dérangé quand on me
dit voilà il suffit pas d'agir il faut
affirmer des crédos mois pour avoir été
élu local j'ai fait en la confiance dans
les élus locaux il faut qu'ils soient
accompagnés
mais le credo ne suffit pas l'action me
semble plus importante
et enfin quand j'entends notre collègue
hommage dire non non nous sommes dans
une écologie positive qu'on accompagne
alors moi je ne demande que ça sauf que
ce qu'on est en train de faire laisse
place à de l'interprétation c'est quand
on me dit qu'à une obligation de
résultat ça veut dire que on a tellement
peu confiance comme une menace au niveau
de la constitution et c'est pas l'objet
de la constitution que je vais prendre
un exemple demain matin quelqu'un décide
de mettre des éoliennes dans dans un
bain dans une commune il y à une
association de gens alors elles sont
toujours citoyenne ces associations s
environnementale
parce qu'elles sont dérangés elles
disent vous menacez l'environnement
qu'est ce qu'on fait et vous vous rendez
compte que au fait courir à isques
pénale qu'on arrivera même pas à
identifier à des élus donc faisant
attention que la créature ne dépasse pas
son créateur et est-ce qu'on peut
raisonner accepter que le sénat
affirment la nécessité d'avancer le
président du sénat l'a dit la nécessité
d'agir et on a zéro sujet là dessus mais
peut-on dire que garantir
moi je je je ne sais pas qui peut
garantir l'obligation d'efficacité parce
qu'on doit être plutôt dans une logique
de développement durable où il y à la
fois l'environnement l'économie et
l'homme c'est comme mon collègue dit on
a tout sacrifié l'économie moi je ne
suis pas d'accord il faut pas oublier au
milieu de tout ça la place de l'homme et
je pense qu'il faut qu'on choix comme
l'est le conseil constitutionnel dans
des appréciations déquilibre bertrand
mathieu est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec bien les inquiétudes que soulèvent
françoise gatel est ce que c'est une
menace dans la constitution
sk
va faire courir et bien d un risque
pénal par exemple sur certains élus à ce
qu'il faut s'inquiéter de cela avec et
bien une telle rédaction aujourd'hui oui
écoutez moi je ne me prononce absolument
pas sur l'aspect politique de la
question mais simplement sur l'aspect
juridique une norme juridique et
notamment une norme constitutionnelle
elle doit présenter deux qualités est
précise et cohérente et je vais
reprendre ces deux poids là sur le plan
de la précision le terme garantie est un
terme qui finalement ne veut pas dire
grand chose soit on le retient dans une
acception très large et ça veut dire
qu'il ya une obligation de résultat ce
qui me paraît irréaliste
on ne peut pas dire que la france à elle
seule va préserver l'environnement et la
diversité biologique soit on dit qu'il
s'agit d'une quasi obligation de
résultat ce sont les termes employés par
le garde des sceaux et moi en tant que
juriste je ne sais pas ce qu'est une
quasi obligation de résultat est là le
risque c'est en effet je me juger de la
responsabilité pénale
deuxième élément un texte noël cohérent
et je rappellerai que on se trouve ici
avec un projet qui ne parlent que de
l'environnement la diversité biologique
et du dérèglement climatique
or dans la charte de l'environnement on
a un texte qui dit qu'il faut concilier
trois éléments le la protection de
l'environnement le développement
économique et la protection sociale
est ce que ces deux textes sont
cohérents non ils sont pas cohérent
puisque la conduit à un équilibre entre
3 objective et l'autre fait que
l'environnement devient une priorité
quasiment excuses et de ce point de vue
je prends un exemple pour dire que ça
peut être amené à contentieux
imaginons dans une commune que cette
commune et un plan d'occupation des sols
qui indique que la moitié des
territoires du territoire de la commune
ne doit pas être artificialisés c'est un
lien ne va pas faire l'objet de
constructions diverses est un exemple
qui a eu 40 les prix ce matin devant la
commission des lois est ce que l'on va
pouvoir attaquer ce plan d'occupation
des textes en deux
de plan d'occupation des sols
pardonnez-moi en considérant qu'il
aurait fallu artificialisés l'ensemble
du territoire de la commune pascal et
vaux bien évidemment on va réduire la
diversité biologique et on voit bien là
qu'il va y avoir une conciliation qui
n'est plus directement impliqués dans la
constitution par exemple entre le droit
au logement et la protection de
l'environnement belle fête je crois que
ce texte
quels qu'en soient les intentions
politiques est un facteur de désordre
normatif
on ne sait pas aujourd'hui ce que les
juges vont faire de ce texte et je crois
que pour les citoyens c'est un élément
d'insécurité juridique et je me bornerai
à cette question là puisque c'est pas à
moi de me prononcer sur les le destin de
la vision oui
anja contentieux ah oui mr savatier
j'adore les constitutionnalistes parce
que ils font toujours de la politique il
ya plusieurs phrases je me permets qui
n'étaient pas des phrases de d'un homme
de loi mais bien des phrases politique
en disant est ce que c'est la france qui
doit préserver à lui tout seul
environnement
ça n'est pas de la corde du tout du
débat constitutionnel c'est une prise de
position politique est là le
positionnement de notre ami
constitutionnaliste et totalement
politique mais c'est toujours
intéressant
non je crois qu'effectivement on est en
train de voir émerger le vrai débat le
vrai débat c'est de dire on n'a pas le
choix on doit préserver l'environnement
on doit tenir nos objectifs climatiques
sinon ne société core la catastrophe
hélas la constitution doit dire ça d'où
le terme garantis mais qu'à partir de là
effectivement nous allons trouver
d'autres compromis dans la société par
rapport aux autres jeux par rapport au
développement économique par rapport à
tous les enjeux de développement social
et dieu sait si les écologistes vont
plus loin que la droite sur la
protection sociale en général dans cet
hémicycle mais que simplement nous
n'allons pas considérer que la variable
d'ajustement c'est l'environnement et là
je crois qu'on passe un cadre et je
pense qu'effectivement il y a encore
dans la société
une part de la société qui
pas aller sur ce grand débat politique
là en disant on a des objectifs et on va
les tenir et on va trouver les compromis
économique et le développement social
qui va avec oui tout de suite on va
rejoindre alexandre poussin pour une
autre réaction celle du sénateur
communiste des bouches du rhône jeremy
manning
oui on le rappelle si le sénat vote
cette révision constitutionnelle de
manière conforme il y aura un référendum
soumis au français jeremy maquis est ce
que derrière ce projet de référendum sur
cette révision constitutionnelle
constitutionnel il y à une manoeuvre
politique d' emmanuel macron alors je
considère que oui alors justement pour
commencer de quoi parle-t-on écocide en
réalité dix motos ultimo logiquement
pardon cela signifie tuer d'autres
maisons et c'est de ça dont il s'agit en
réalité aujourd'hui on a une planète qui
est à feu et à sang et qui dépérit
chaque jour un peu plus et au détriment
des générations futures et de l'avenir
aujourd'hui nous avons la volonté comme
d'ailleurs la convention citoyenne sur
le climat nous communistes que ce soit à
une crime déco side qui puisse être
reconnu et pas simplement une des ligues
là on parle de la révision de l'article
1er
la france garantit la biodiversité et la
préservation de l'environnement sur ça
évidemment on parlait de manoeuvre vous
me posiez la question est ce qu'il
s'agit d'une manoeuvre politicienne
d'emmanuel macron je considère qu'en
réalité déjà ne savons pas si les
élections départementales et régionales
vont pouvoir se tenir dans des
conditions normales soit au mois de juin
soit l'automne prochain cela
signifierait que nous pourrions avoir
dès l'automne prochaine trois élections
en réalité au même moment ils j'y vois
effectivement de la part du président
macron l'opportunité d'avoir une
élection qui pourrait gagner
éventuellement celle du référendum à
défaut de gagner des régions ou des
départements à travers le pays donc on
voit bien en réalité qui alla tout une
stratégie extrêmement politicienne pour
se donner une dynamique une petite
bouffée d'oxygène à quelques mois
de l'élection présidentielle sachant
qu'ils avaient chaud aussi de
l'environnement de l'écologie une des
priorités du quinquennat il a beaucoup
déçu on se rappelle d'ailleurs de la
démission de son ministre l'écologie
nicolas hulot à l'époque on a entendu
les retours et la note calamiteuse
d'ailleurs du conseil du 2 de la
convention celle-ci moyenne par dont
deux sur le climat dont ni au président
de la république sur l'intégration des
propositions de cette convention à la
politique gouvernementale
est ce que ce n'est pas aussi un piège
pour les oppositions parlementaires qui
est bien refuserait de voter conforme
cette révision constitutionnelle de
l'amendé voilà de voter un texte
différent et donc d'annuler le
référendum
non mais je crois que nous devrons avoir
un débat démocratique on ne peut pas
dire le texte il est à prendre ou à
laisser en l'état on a un parlement et
sénat une assemblée nationale qui sont
aussi force de propositions qui sont
aussi pour l'assemblée nationale
émanation du peuple nous aussi des
territoires et on nous avons tout
intérêt pour le coup enrichir index qui
est de mon point de vue extrêmement
bancal pour l'heure et qui nécessite un
véritable drame ailleurs agissements de
prêtres présenter éventuellement aux
françaises et aux français dans quelques
mois donc vous sénateurs communistes
vous allez proposer des modifications
des amendements à cette révision
constitutionnelle effectivement avec
l'ensemble du groupe c'est pas moi tout
seul qui prendrait évidemment est la
décision c'est une réflexion que nous
avons
parce que nous trouvons que le texte ne
va pas assez loin en tout cas il n'est
pas assez en accord avec les
préconisations encore été formulée et
surtout avec les enjeux de notre société
de notre temps merci beaucoup merci
jérémy vaquier d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup alexandre votre réaction
prisca thévenot à ce que vient de dire
le sénateur il parle d'une opportunité
politique
on a parlé du fond de la de la rédaction
de l'article 1er mai la forme ça va être
très bien celle du référendum est ce que
c'est une un coup politique aussi pour
emmanuel macron bien qu'à quelques mois
de la présidentielle
non je pense pas s'agit pas de
manoeuvres politiques ou d'intentions
politiques
il s'agit justement d'écouter d'entendre
une volonté une une priorité citoyenne
qui a été notamment mis en place est dit
par la convention 6
moyenne pour le climat et d'y répondre
de façon politique
ensuite je voudrais répondre
effectivement à ce qui a été dire oui il
y a le l'ambition colite l'ambition
écologique du gouvernement ne s'arrête
pas à cette à cette révision de la
constitution énormément de choses sont à
venir notamment sur le projet de loi qui
met résilience mais d'autres choses ont
déjà été faits depuis le début du
quinquennat
et je suis désolé qu'il ne s'en
souviennent pas mais pour l'enrayer
quelques-unes par exemple nous sommes le
premier pays au monde à avoir interdit
dès 2017 les recherches d'hydrocarbures
sur le territoire national nous aurons
fermé l'intégralité des centrales à
charbon d'ici la fin du quinquennat
il ya également une grande loi mobilité
qui a été mis en place une loi sur
l'économie circulaire donc je pense que
ça serait faux de dire que rien n'a été
fait et je pense que ça serait faux de
dire qu'il s'agit juste d'une démarche
politique puisque de nombreux citoyens
la demande et il s'agit de l'entente
effectivement d'y répondre
bertrand mathieu voudrais qu'on parle un
petit peu de la forme que ça va
apprendre puisque depuis 1958 la france
a connu neuf référendum d'intérêt
national la plupart du temps cela s'est
passé via l'article 11 sur proposition
de l'exécutif là emmanuel macron choisi
l'article 89 qui requiert l'accord des
trois cinquièmes du parlement quel est
le sens de cette démarche de vouloir et
bien bien le vote des trois cinquièmes
du parlement avant le référendum
oui simplement si vous le permettez je
répondrai aux sénateurs qui m'a ils sont
la dimension politique de mode mais
simplement il n'y a pas de dimension
politique je dis simplement que
techniquement je dis simplement que
techniquement je ne vois pas comment la
france a elle même à elles seules
arriverait à préserver l'environnement
respecter ses engagements internationaux
vous croyez c'est tout mais alors dans
ce cas là il faudrait dire qu'elle
participe à la garonne oui c'est déjà
trop je serai expression juridique la
plus juste c'est simplement mon
observation sur le recours au référendum
j'allais dire que si on entre dans cette
logique là moi je trouve que le recours
au référendum est une chose
une bonne chose c'est légitime la
procédure qu'a choisi le président la
république et la procédure normale de
révision de la constitution
on utilise très peu à partir du moment
où il ya une volonté politique et encore
une fois c'est pas à moi de juger de
cette volonté politique
il est tout à fait normal de demander
aux électeurs de delà de la valider et
je crois qu'en effet on a recouru
beaucoup trop rarement au référendum
une convention n'est pas le peuple
français
et si on veut une modification
importante recourir au peuple français
après un vote par les deux assemblées me
semble parfaitement légitime sur le plan
juridique
vous êtes d'accord avec cela françoise
gatel ce référendum avec ces deux étapes
les 3 5e du parlement ça mais aussi les
parlementaires face à leurs
responsabilités et ensuite la validation
finale par ou pas par le peuple français
oui alors moi je n'ai aucune gêne avec
le référendum c'est très bien mais sauf
que on a des tas d'exemples où les gens
ont utilisé le référendum comme un
plébiscite pour ou contre le
gouvernement il ya une dimension très
personnelle
voilà à présent a établi ce lien entre
l'eczéma la deuxièmement on consulte nos
concitoyens moi je m'en réjouis mais il
faudrait aussi qu'on les informe en
disant qu'il n'y a pas rien dans la
constitution ce serait quand même bien
de le rappeler troisièmement je voudrais
qu'on rappelle et je pense que notre
collègue qui confond la constitution et
la loi que c'est par la loi que l'on va
faire des choses parce que c'est pas
simplement en criant environnement
environnement de gaulle disait comme le
europe europe comme un cabri val ça n'a
pas marché
voilà et enfin je trouve moi j'entends
quand on me dit vous comprenez c'est la
convention citoyenne qui l'a décidé donc
on doit mettre les intentions de la
convention citoyenne en oeuvre
je voudrais juste rappeler sans nier
l'intérêt des conventions aussi perdre
la démocratie participative que nous
sommes dans une démocratie où il y à une
démocratie représentative et que quand
même je serai un peu surprise étonné
voire un peu
profondément choqués qu'on interdise au
sénat de débattre du sujet et que l'on
dise le sénat il doit accepter ça parce
que c'est la convention citoyenne et
s'il le fait pas c'est parce que il
refuse la consultation des gens ils
refusent des classes mois ne soyons pas
caricaturaux et faisant attention à ce
qu'on dit et ne chantons pas le
parlement qui aujourd'hui est un espace
de démocratie représentative dont nous
ne cessons de dire parfois qu'il n'ait
pas été consultés et associés
eh bien merci merci à tous les cadres
d'avoir participé à ce débat
on n'a pas fait parler de ce sujet a
noté d'ailleurs qu'à 16h45 vous pourrez
suivre l'audition d'eric dupond-moretti
le garde des sceaux donc qui va
s'exprimer devant la commission des lois
du sénat autour de cette révision
constitutionnelle qui vise donc à
inscrire de l'environnement dans
l'article 1er nous sommes maintenant un
petit peu moins d'une demi heure des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
tous nos journalistes sont en place
alexandre poussard salle des conférences
jean masia qui anime son émission sénat
stream sur twitch et puis steve jourdain
dans l'hémicycle du sénat
steve laissez moi deviner on va parler
qu'aux vide dans l'hémicycle c'est
d'après midi sous quel angle vous savez
toute âme la crise sanitaire qui encore
et toujours en haut de l'affiché sur la
question et bien des élections
régionales et départementales cet après
midi ces élections vous le savez elle
aurait dû se tenir le week-end dernier
elles ont été reportées au mois de juin
prochain pour cause de crise sanitaire
alors est-ce qu'elles pourront bel et
bien se tenir au regard notamment de
l'évolution inquiétante des chiffres de
l'épidémie
le conseil scientifique doit rendre son
avis d'ici et bien au 1er avril est le
gouvernement sera interpellé à ce sujet
cet après midi par les sénateurs le coc
vide c'est aussi la fermeture des petits
commerces avec l'annoncé d'un nouveau
bond à nouveau confinement par le
gouvernement la semaine dernière 90
milles commerce jugés non essentiels ont
dû fermer leurs portes les sénateurs
vont interpeller le gouvernement sur la
nécessité de maintenir voire d'amplifier
les aides économiques à destination et
bien de ce secteur et puis il y aura
aussi une question plus large une
question plus générale sur la stratégie
vaccinale
du gouvernement pourquoi ce mot
oscillant en france a vacciné hier
emmanuel macron a annoncé l'ouverture à
la vaccination pour les personnes de
plus de 70 ans à partir de la fin de
cette semaine pas suffisant pour les
sénateurs les sénateurs qui vont
interpeller le gouvernement sur la
stratégie vaccinale à moyen terme les
questions d'actualité cédant maintenant
un peu moins de 30 minutes m merci merci
beaucoup stif pour toutes ces
explications rendez vous dans une
demi-heure classe à présent notre face à
face on va parler ensemble est bien de
la pandémie plus précisément de l'école
dans la pandémie les protocoles
sanitaires sont ils à la hauteur faut-il
vacciner prioritairement les enseignants
faut-il fermer les écoles face à la
pression sanitaire deux invités sur ce
pôle top en débattre max brisson bonjour
jour vous êtes sénateur les républicains
des pyrénées atlantiques vice président
de la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation est avec nous céline brulin
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice communiste
de la seine-maritime et membre de la
commission de la culture et de
l'éducation
gardez les écoles ouvertes en dépit de
la pandémie c'est au tour 3 c'est en
tout cas le choix qui a été fait
jusqu'ici par l'exécutif
est ce le bon on va se poser la question
après le point sur ce sujet avec sandra
sert qu'a le gouvernement pourra-t-il
tenir son engagement de garder coûte que
coûte les écoles ouvertes
le nombre de contaminations explose en
partie parce que les enfants sont
davantage testé à l'école quinze mille
cas positif en début de semaine contre
moins de 9300 la semaine précédente
les cas de covile progresse aussi chez
les personnels plus de 1800 cas au 19
mars contre 1100 il y a dix jours
certains spécialistes affirment que les
écoles ne doivent pas fermée pour
d'autres les maintenir ouvertes et
risquée est difficilement tenable
l'épidémiologiste arnaud fontanet
recommande de dédoubler les classes au
collège pour casser les chaînes de
contamination et n'exclut pas une
fermeture des établissements si les
chiffres empire et trois pays qui ont
affronté une épidémie dujarrier anglais
ou lisez le royaume uni l'irlande et le
portugal ne s'en sont sortis avec une
fermeture complète maintenant si on
arrivait en passant en alternance
collèges et lycées oui avec les mesures
sanitaires dont on a parlé et en
renforçant le dépistage a gardé les
écoles ouverts
ce serait très bien parce
qu'effectivement les écoles sont le
dernier endroit à fermer sur le terrain
les écoles touchées par le coc u19 ont
de plus en plus de mal à faire face aux
absences d'enseignants difficile de
trouver des remplaçants
les syndicats comme l'unsa réclame des
moyens supplémentaires pour maintenir
les écoles ouvertes quand les élèves
sont là les autres l'ex sont tenus de
les accueillir dans leur classe ce qui
donne beaucoup de brassage d'élèves au
mépris de des règles sanitaires et au
mépris aussi de la qualité du travail
qu'on peut mener il faut éviter au
maximum que les enseignants tombe malade
et pour cela la vaccination s'impose la
vaccination contre le coc vide attendu
par les enseignants emmanuel macron a
annoncé que ce serait possible courant
avril mais seulement si le nombre de
vaccins disponibles le permet voilà la
france a donc choisi de garder coûte que
coûte aujourd'hui ces écoles ouverts ce
n'est pas le cas de tous les pays
européens si on fait le bilan de la
pandémie nous faisons plutôt figure
d'exception regarder la france est bien
depuis début la pandémie à fermer ses
écoles dix semaines l'italie 7 30
semaines l'allemagne 24 semaines le
royaume-uni 26 semaines max brisson est
ce que c'est une exception française
dont il faut être fier ou un risque
sanitaire qui ai pris un risque
peut-être exagéré je suis très fier de
cette exception française et ailleurs en
france l'école est exceptionnel
le rapport à l'école très particulier
fait partie des gènes du pays
c'est pas le même dans les autres pays
d'europe nous avons fermé l'école
pendant quelques semaines lors du
premier confinant à dix on a vu
l'étendue du désastre
donc il faut tout faire pour garder les
écoles ouvertes c'est pas les epide
ministre qui gouverne ce pays dont le
gouvernement pour l'instant cela sur
l'idée de les laisser ouvertes
il a raison louve la manière dont on
était frères mis brutalement au mode
mars moi je me rappelle le ministre
éducation nationale l'avant veille avait
dit qu'elle ne serait pas fermé a
maintenant ton était plus fermé
brutalement a eu des effets dévastateurs
il faut aussi que l'eau il ya là
convient d'une part il ya l'état moral
psychique du pays et la situation
sociale du pays
l'école est un lieu essentiel pour
beaucoup d'enfants de ce pays l'apathie
ceux des milieux
les plus défavorisés moi je milite pour
qu'on garde les écoles ouvertes
céline brulin c'est un choix politique
pour éviter les catastrophes éducative
pour vous ça reste judicieux y compris
dans les 16 départements confiné à même
si on sait pas vraiment si on est
confiné dont fait notamment partie la
seine maritime
pour moi le sujet ce n'est pas ouvrir ou
fermer les écoles c'est que faut-il
faire pour maintenir les écoles ouvertes
parce qu'effectivement on a besoin que
les enfants que les jeunes puissent
continuer à aller à l'école les parents
d'ailleurs majoritairement le trouve
aussi parce que pour tous ceux qui ont
expérimenté l'école à la maison au
printemps dernier ils ont perçu pour
ceux qui en doutaient encore l'utilité
de l'école mais du coup ça veut pas être
l'école comme d'habitude il ya des
mesures à mettre en oeuvre
ma part les proto d'orelsan il l'entend
et voyant déjà que l'elysée n'ait ancien
gang qui vient d'intervenir disait à
juste titre qu'on a un sujet avec les
remplacements de carte scolaire qu'on
supprime à nouveau des postes dans
certains endroits que bien souvent ce
sont des difficultés de remplacements au
bout du bout et on arrive à des
aberrations qui font que les gamins sont
brassées dans les classes parce que
l'enseignant qui est absent voit ses
enfants et ses élèves répartis dans
d'autres classes donc oui il faut et
puis il faut des tests il faut
effectivement vaccinés les enseignants
le plus vite possible et c'est comme ça
qu'on permettra de maintenir l'école en
fonction on s'interroge donc
effectivement aujourd'hui sur
l'efficacité du protocole sanitaire
ainsi on résume aujourd'hui et bien
écoles maternelles élémentaires et
collèges reste ouvert les lycées sont en
2000 jauge le masque est obligatoire à
partir de 6 ans à l'école alors il ya eu
une petite nouveauté c'est que le sport
en interne est à nouveau autorisée dans
les écoles depuis l'allocution de
de jean castex à la semaine dernière où
sont les angles morts pour vous ou est
ce qu'il faut améliorer le protocole
sanitaire max brisson parle beaucoup de
la cantine je pointais je parlais aussi
bien de sa question du sport en
intérieur on peut aussi s'interroger
légitimement sur le sujet je pense pas
que les sujets majeurs soit là je fais
confiance par exemple ou aux équipes sur
le terrain aux professeurs des écoles
aux directeurs aux élus locaux aux
réseaux aux agents des collectivités
territoriales pour faire ce qu'il faut
par exemple au moment des tentes de
restauration je suis persuadé on a faim
les équipements et vous savez je suis
lui donné partant il ya beaucoup de
petites communes vous veut pas savoir
les trésors d'imagination des mères de
leurs joueurs
même sans personnel pour que la cantine
fonctionne pour que l'école fonctionne
l'attachement à l'école dans ce pays et
surtout en zone rurale est telle que les
maires sont capables de passer des
journées entières pour être sûrs que
leur école fonctionne donc moi j'ai pas
beaucoup de craintes surtout dans les
écoles ou qui manquent de personnel
parce qu'il ya l'intelligente et
territoires parce qu'il ya le trésor de
dévouement des équipes d'élus locaux par
rapport à leur école parce qu'ils se
battent mater mid-swap pour que leur
école reste ouverte parce que l'école
c'est la vie du village
tôt ce sujet là par contre il ya des
trous dans la raquette et qui sont
considérables la professeure le disais
tout à l'heure
la vaccination des enseignants il ya des
trous dans la raquette sur la capacité
quand il ya risque de dépister
massivement pour isoler finalement
l'école est confronté à la faillite de
la politique sanitaire du gouvernement à
la manière dont ce gouvernement n'a pas
su était toujours en retard dans la
manière de gérer la lutte contre la
corrida
les tests qui ont manqué les matches qui
ont manqué aux plaques citation qui a
pris du retard et tout ça se répercute
sur l'école mais c'est pas et la réponse
serait on ferme on laisse le métro
ouvert nos fermes les musées on
laisserait le métro ouvert mais on ferme
les écoles non il ne faut pas formés
fermer l'école et il faut répondre en
termes de tests et en termes de
vaccination on va parler vaccination
céline brulin mais un mot d'abord sur ce
protocole sanitaire est ce que pour vous
aujourd'hui il est à la hauteur à ce que
on a des règles suffisamment strictes
est ce que les écoles ont les moyens de
les appliquer je regardais par exemple
aux états unis.le
byden inclut des subventions aux
collectivités pour faire des travaux
d'aération dans les écoles des
purificateurs d'air est appelé par les
choses aussi avec un simple qui au
moment du plf avait indiqué le budget
que le budget absolument que les sommes
qui étaient destinés aux collectivités
pour faire face aux protocoles
sanitaires étaient vraisemblablement
insuffisante et partout sur le terrain
les élus témoigne en effet de moyens
matériels humains il y en a qui ont
construit des sanitaires enfin il ya eu
effectivement un trésors d'intelligence
développer je veux dit je pensais en
écoutant à l'instant max brisson à cette
commune d'un département normand qui est
celui de l'heure où ce sont les élus eux
mêmes qui vont faire la cantine pour
pouvoir continuer à accueillir dans une
salle des fêtes pour pouvoir continuer à
accueillir les enfants donc tout ça se
fait donc oui on a besoin de moyens et
puis ya besoin de tester par exemple
moi j'ai l'impression que les opérations
de tests qui ont démarré après les
vacances d'hiver opérations de tests
salivaires dans les écoles notamment été
vraiment insuffisant j'ai parfois
l'impression que ça a été un peu de là
comme pour montrer que des choses se
faisait sur le terrain mais on en est
pas à la politique qui permet
véritablement d'enrayer l'épidémie de la
lacc on s'y concentrer là où on trouve
des cas et je pense qu'il faut vraiment
franchir un cap sur ce sur ce niveau là
comme effectivement sur la vaccination
les enseignants notamment dans les
départements comme le mien qui viennent
d'être confiné ne comprennent pas qu'on
n'augmente les mesures qu'on dit de
freinage puisqu'on a pu le raz-de-marée
de confinement mais que eux ne souhaite
toujours pas vaccinées alors que depuis
le début il le demande le président de
la république en tout cas a annoncé hier
est bien le début de la vaccination des
enseignants pour le mois d'avril
on les écoute nos enseignants ont fait
l'objet d'une campagne de tests comme
d'ailleurs les élèves que nous avons
fortement déployés ces dernières
semaines nous allons le poursuivre et
dès que nous le pourrons
je souhaite qu'on puisse en effet avoir
une campagne de vaccination dédiés
simplement au moment où je vous parle
nous sommes encore dans une phase on
doit faire monter en charge le vaccin et
compte tenu du nombre d'enseignants que
nous avons dans notre pays je pense que
ce ne serait pas responsable de vous
dire aujourd'hui où la semaine prochaine
on peut le faire à partir de mi fin
avril nous allons avoir de plus en plus
de vaccins qui vont arriver et on sera à
ce moment là dans une situation qui nous
permettra en effet d'envisager d'avoir
des campagnes ciblées sur des
professions qui sont exposés à qui on
demande des efforts
les enseignants font légitimement partir
max brisson vous entendez le président
de la république et par le demi fin
avril mais reste très prudent parce qu
on comprend bien que ça dépend et bien
sûr des stocks qu'on va avoir à
disposition en france
à ce moment là ça fait un homme que dans
12 mois ce sera pierre veilleux est à
peu près le discours permanent de
l'exécutif moi je veux bien et j'espère
que les vaccins seront au rendez-vous et
que les professeurs pourront être
vaccinés pour pouvoir faire le métier en
sérénité
c'est au mythique besoin de beaucoup de
mobilisations et donc de l'exercer en
sérénité
mais on a des cas actuel est extrêmement
concret que le gouvernement pourrait
rêver je viens de poser une question
écrite au gouvernement sur le
financement des cantines la manière dont
l'administration a limité la capacité
pour l'état d'aider les cantines
scolaires de financer les quintés colère
sur les surcoûts liés à la coved fait
que dans mon département la plupart y
compris saint-honoré vraiment besoin
qu'ils ont des petites communes ne sont
pas éligibles
donc on a une volonté politique affirmée
et pour l'administration par derrière
qui avait oublié des choses demain
parce que le nombre de communes
éligibles au fonds cantine sont
extrêmement faibles dans wall-e discours
je veux bien
il y a des choses très concrètes qui
permettraient en effet au maire pas
simplement d'un fr travaux département
ça existe aussi la cantine
la restauration organisée le service de
la pause méridienne dans le gymnase mais
qui aurait aussi besoin des deux recours
pour assurer des recrutements
nécessaires pour respecter les
protocoles dans des discours du
président république que c'est bien mais
rentrer dans le concret et ne pas à peu
près mettre en oeuvre le contraire de ce
qui est dit dans les discours ça serait
beaucoup mieux
on va continuer à parler de la
vaccination on va regarder ensemble un
petit peu ce qu'il en est un de la
situation des enseignants dans le monde
il ya des pays où les enseignants sont
prioritaires à la vaccination
c'est le cas en italie en espagne ou
encore au portugal mais aussi aux états
unis où la campagne a géré par les par
les états et où joe biden s'est fixé
comme objectif que tous les enseignants
aient reçu une dose d'ici fin mars les
enseignants à l'école primaire sont
prioritaires en allemagne ils ne sont
pas prioritaires en france en finlande
en suède
vous vous demandez qu'ils soient
vaccinés prioritairement céline brulin
tout de suite
est ce que vous vous satisfait de ce que
vous avez entendu du président de la
république qui dit mi-avril facile si on
a le même président de la république
disait il ya à peu près trois semaines
qu'on pourrait tout ré ouvrir en avril
donc moi je suis peiné de voir que la
parole publique et celle du président de
la république en particulier soit si
légère
on a un problème de pénurie de vaccins
qui pose beaucoup de questions sur nos
capacités en matière de recherche sur
nos capacités industrielles et moi je
fais partie de ceux qui pensent qu'il
faut lever les brevets sur ses vaccins
pour qu'on puisse en produire beaucoup
plus massivement parce qu'aujourd'hui on
se retrouve dans une situation qui est
difficile pour tout le monde c'est à
chercher qui est plus prioritaire que
l'autre et ça ça ne peut générer que de
la division que du mécontentement que de
l'inquiétude est donc oui il faut
accélérer et dans les publics
prioritaires il ya évidemment les
enseignants parce qu'ils sont tout
simplement confronté à d
dizaine d'enfants et d'élèves chaque
jour et que si on veut maintenir l'école
ouverte que les enseignants puissent
continuer d'accueillir les enfants et de
dispenser des enseignements oui il faut
qu'il fasse partie des publics
prioritaires
elle est on va à présent rejoindre notre
streamer politique jean m'assieds salut
genre à nouveau rebonjour quoi de neuf
avec et bien tous les streamer qui sont
avec toi qu'est-ce qui vous intéresse
vous interpelle dans les questions qui
vont être abordés va d'ici un quart
d'heure maintenant et bien écoute tamia
plusieurs sujets qui intéressent les
internautes ya la question des mesures
pour les étudiants on avait beaucoup
parlé ces dernières semaines on se
souvient de fric comme eric vidal
emmanuel macron était monté au créneau
pour annoncer des aides spécifiques pour
les étudiants mais voilà ils sont
nombreux les internautes à dire que de
plus en plus d'étudiants ont quand même
recours à l'aide alimentaire visiblement
les aides apportées par le gouvernement
ne suffisent pas est ce que frédéric
vidal pourrait revenir sur ce sujet là
pour peut-être annoncé de nouvelles
choses ça c est attendue pour cet après
midi une autre question qui est sur la
mise en place d vaccinodromes tu sais
ces centres de vaccination géants dans
des stades entiers dans des centres
sportifs c'est intéressant comment ça va
se mettre en place là on aurait besoin
de précisions de la part du ministre de
la santé
quand est ce qu'on va être invité
convoqué comment ça va se mettre en
place comment ça va s'organiser
on commence à on commence à de plus en
plus intéressés à 7 à cette campagne de
vaccination grand public à partir de à
partir de mi avril on l'espère en tout
cas
et une dernière question qui intéresse
les internautes c'est la montée des
tensions entre l'union européenne et la
chine sur fond de chansons de sanctions
réciproque entre les deux géants avec la
avec avec la sphère de l'oppression des
ouïghours
ça inquiète un petit peu et voilà
beaucoup d'internautes aimerait bien
peut-être entendre le quai d'orsay s'est
exprimé sur ce sujet là et voir quelle
est la position de la france vis-à-vis
de la chine
voilà des sujets pour aujourd'hui qu'on
attend merci beaucoup gens on va voir si
et bien le gouvernement va répondre de
façon satisfaisante à toutes ces
questions alors j'ai un peu surprise
parce que tu n'as pas parler et bien de
la polémique qu'il ya aujourd'hui autour
d'eux
l'unef l'organisation de réunions non
mixtes y va y avoir d'ailleurs une
question à ce sujet tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle et tout de suite on va
rejoindre alexandre poussard qui se
trouve avec et bien stéphane le rudulier
sénateurs à l'est républicain
et bien lui même réclame d'ailleurs la
dissolution de l'unef alexandre
effectivement stéphane le rudulier vous
avez adressé un courrier au ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin signé par
une trentaine de sénateurs de droite où
vous demander la dissolution de ce
syndicat étudiant l'unef
après les révélations sur ces réunions
non mixtes interdite aux blancs la
dissolution de l'unef qui a quand même
un syndicat historique
est ce que ça ne va pas un peu loin non
je ne pense pas je pense qu'il faut
envoyer un message fort
est ce que un syndicat des étudiant es
là pour promouvoir le séparatisme et le
communautarisme je ne pense pas
syndicats d'étudiants il est là pour
défendre les intérêts des étudiants et
il ya un véritable sujet aujourd'hui
quand on regarde la de la crise
sanitaire
et là je pense que l'unef a été trop
loin c'est pas la première fois il ya eu
déjà le dérapage de de l'igp et de
grenoble
rappelons le est au vu de leurs
positions qui sont de plus en plus
extrémistes et je pèse mes mots je pense
que le syndicat l'unef n'a plus rien à
voir avec un syndicat d'étudiants bien
de bien au delà il va contre nos valeurs
de la république nos principes nos
idéaux et donc à partir de là il faut
prendre des mesures des mesures fermes
comme
on a prises d'ailleurs sur le groupe
génération identitaire donc vous
comparez une f1 génération identitaire
écoutez ce sont un peu les mêmes causes
même si effectivement l'objet est
différent mais la cause reste totalement
identique c'est qu'on promeut le
communautarisme on fait des groupes
racialisées des réunions non mixtes
interdit aux blancs imaginer un seul
instant si un syndicat d'étudiants
avaient organisé des réunions non mixtes
interdit aux noirs en gisements aux
juifs aux asiatiques je pense que la
réponse doit être aussi faire que dans
ce cas que j'expose vous parlez de
séparatisme est ce que ça veut dire que
dans le débat prochain au sénat sur le
projet de loi de lutte contre les
séparatistes
il va être question de l'université
absolument il faudra je pense durcir
certains dispositifs législatifs
notamment pour que le décret qui est
pris en conseil me conseille des
ministres s'agissant de la dissolution
on puisse avoir tous les arguments dans
le cadre de la loi parce que le débat
juridique qui se pose sur cette
dissolution c'est que ces réunions ne
sont pas en fait public donc dès lors il
ya une faille juridique et je pense que
ce projet de loi devra répondre à cette
faille juridique
merci beaucoup c'était fin le régulier
pour votre réaction autour de cette
polémique sur le syndicat étudiant
l'unef
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
première réaction votre réaction céline
brulin sûr et bien cet appel de
plusieurs sénateurs
heller à dissoudre l'unef et puis
stéphanie reculé à l'instant on vient de
comparer l'unef a generation identitaire
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
ça m'inspire que nous sommes dans une
situation très grave lorsque un
parlementaire vient de comparer comme
cela vient d'être fait l'unef a
generation identitaire je pense qu'il se
passe des choses gravissimes dans notre
pays et que les républicains et je pense
aux partis politiques les républicains
mais je pense à tous les républicains
quand on entend ce genre de choses il
est vraiment temps de ré
dir on peut ne pas être d'accord avec la
manière dont l'unef mène ses combats est
ce qu'il ya une radicalisation tout de
même de l'unef à mai mais je pense qu'on
est dans une situation où ça a été
développé à l'instant les étudiants sans
tourner dans une situation de précarité
absolue
l'année dernière à la même époque les
français découvraient avec effroi la
situation nos hôpitaux ou des soignants
prenez des sacs poubelle pour ce faire
des blues
et bien aujourd'hui la france découvre
avec effroi la situation de nos
étudiants
et c'est bien le dernier moment où il
faut dissoudre des syndicats étudiants
dans la période que nous vivons
max brisson alors moi je ne demande pas
la discussion de l'unef
mais l'unef est allé trop loin je suis
tout à fait sur la position de bruno
retailleau qui a écrit au garde des
sceaux
il faut que le parquet et entame des
poursuivent pas contre l'unef en général
et contre les dirigeants qui font cette
provocation d'un tigre à gagny serena
mixte qui va parce qu'à l'université
aujourd'hui
iliad était importée des états unis
indigéniste racialiste qui sont à
l'opposé de notre conception universelle
de la citoyenneté
donc il faut les combattre est il une
sève aujourd'hui peut-être infiltrés par
ces tests comme un certain nombre
d'éléments de l'université se l'était
dit l'univers l'unef a une histoire
c'est un grand grand scénic h2 de gauche
certes c'est un grand syndicat étudiant
qui a sa place dans cette histoire donc
moi je n'ai pas demandé la dissolution
cela n'exonère pas les responsables
politiques et la justice de faire dans
le cadre d'un débat contradictoire leur
travail parce qu'un effet faire du
communautarisme et l'affiché et en faire
une profession de foi c'est contraire
aux valeurs de république et je pense
que l'unef et dans l'histoire de la
république à elle de nous prouver sur ce
même sujet on va tout de suite rejoindre
alexandre poussard car vous êtes avec le
sénateur socialiste
rémi garde ont toujours pour parler de
cette polémique autour de l'unef et âme
avec le sénateur socialiste et rémy
chardon
plus jeune sénateur de l'histoire rémy
chardon votre réaction à ces sénateurs
de droite une trentaine de sénateurs qui
appelle à dissoudre le syndicat étudiant
l'unef votre réaction on est très simple
c'est qu'ils alimentent la polémique
lancée par le gouvernement qui était bon
que quand les propos de madame vidal sur
l'islam aux gauchistes caractérisée en
tout cas qu'il y avait quelque chose de
pas clair notamment à lunettes mais pas
que et donc là encore une fois je trouve
ça dommage le sujet d'actualité devrait
être l'urgence sociale chez les jeunes
on voit les banques alimentaires se
remplir de plus en plus on voit la
difficulté qu'ils ont d'un point de vue
psychologique et là vous voyez que le
sujet d'actualité c'est les propos de
l'unef sérieusement quand est-ce qu'on
pourrait revenir par un débat de qui a
en tout cas du sens puisqu'il ya des
jeunes qui sont derrière tout ça et qui
attendent des vraies réponses du
gouvernement sur l'urgence sociale non
pour vous ces réunions non mixtes où les
blancs ne sont pas invités pour vous
faut mettre sous le tapis on n'en parle
pas c'est ya eu effectivement une dérive
dans les propos mais encore une fois le
sujet doit être l'urgence sociale chez
les jeunes arrêtons en fait on est en
train de se faire enfumer par le
gouvernement et les élèves et leur
permet aussi de revenir dans les débats
identitaires
est ce qu'aujourd'hui sérieusement on
peut aller débattre avec un étudiant ou
avec un jeune devant en banque
alimentaire sur les sujets sur le
séparatisme ce sujet identitaire est ce
que le sujet ce n'est pas forcément
d'urgence sociale elle est la difficulté
à s'insérer professionnellement
peut-être revenir sur le coeur du
problème et j'ai l'impression qu'on fait
du coup les sénateurs aient l'air le
gouvernement est encore déconnecté face
à la réalité quoi voilà alors bien sûr
il ya la question de l'urgence sociale
et on en parle souvent
notamment dans des émissions mais quand
même dans quelques semaines on va parler
de séparatisme ici au sénat ces réunions
étudiante non mixtes et que est ce que
quand même c'est un sujet c'est un
problème encore une fois c'est marrant
parce que les sénateurs aient l'air
était avait l'occasion de débattre sur
l'urgence sociale
le 20 janvier sur une ppl le notamment
sur l'extension du rsa ça les a pas
pourquoi intéressé il y avait 3 3
sénateurs hier dans l'hémicycle
et aujourd'hui c'est bien évidemment des
sujets comme le séparatisme sujets
identitaires saleh de ça les attire
encore une fois est-ce que ça
sérieusement discuté avec des étudiants
ce sujet ils vont ils vont vous dire ce
n'est pas un sujet d'actualité
sujet d'actualité c'est comment on mange
comme on s'interroge comment on fait
pour manger ce soir
et comment on peut être un peu plus
gérer en meilleure forme
psychologiquement c'est ça le sujet chez
les étudiants arrêtons de lance de
d'alimenter des polémiques lancées par
gouvernement alors en tout cas la
direction du parti socialiste aurait vu
olivier faure a dénoncé ces réunions du
syndicat de l'unef et il ya d'autres
partis de gauche qui eux justifient ces
réunions pour libérer la parole des
personnes discriminées
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la france
insoumise d'europe écologie les verts
qui justifie ces réunions mixtes
rapidement écoutez moi je ne connais que
j'ai envie déjà envie de pleurer bas
reviennent sur des sujets autour de
l'urgence sociale
s'il vous plaît d'accord merci beaucoup
aimé cardon d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
voilà rémy chardon qui botte plutôt en
touche sur jury
je pense qu'on a mieux c'est de l'
amalgame on parlait du riant sociale oui
un problème quel rapport avec des thèses
importé des états unis contraire aux
valeurs de la république qui remettent
en cause notre constitution
nos valeurs nos principes quand
sénateurs socialistes ne parlent que
d'urgence ou sac
oui elle existe logement social je ne
nie pas je la vis au quotidien dans mon
mandat mais par contre ni nier qu'ils
actuelle mort dans une partie des élites
françaises
un abandon des principes de la
révolution française qu'un sénateur
socialiste aux ainsi répondre aux
urgences sociales
quand on lui parle de tout cas sont
extrêmement graves qui aient la bande
d'eau dans certains nombres par la
gauche française
une partie de la gauche française pierre
ouzou bias ou céline brulin j'en suis
sûr n'aurait pas répondu la même manière
on ne peut pas laisser abandonner
abandonné des valeurs aussi fortes que
l'universalisme républicain sur julien
d'ordre nous scandalise scandalisé bon
allez on continue les réactions salle
des conférences on va rejoindre jacques
fernique il est à votre micro alexandre
le sénateur écologiste du bas rhin pour
une réaction à une autre polémique celle
qui monte autour du financement public
de la mosquée de strasbourg
effectivement entame la mairie de
strasbourg la mairie écologistes de
strasbourg qui s'est déclaré favorable
au principe d'une subvention à la
construction d'une mosquée par une
association musulmane qui est suspecté
d'islamisme politique sous l' influence
de l'état turc jacques fernique est ce
que la mairie strasbourg a bien fait de
d'accorder cette subvention à la mairie
de strasbourg elle a poursuivi ce qu'on
engageait les municipalités précédentes
ce projet pas nouveau cette mosquée moi
mon lycée où j'enseignais ya encore
quelques mois juste à côté
les deux tiers du gros oeuvre sont déjà
faits roland ries maire de strasbourg a
posé la première pierre en présence du
préfet de l'époque
l'essentiel des listes aux municipales
avant le deuxième tour rencontrait
fréquentait les animateurs de cette
association
si darmanin si l'état à des éléments
nous montrant qu effectivement les
principes de la république sont en cause
qui les disent qu'ils les donnent
d'ailleurs strasbourg a été prudent en
la matière le conseil municipal n'a pas
validé définitivement principe la
subvention il l'a conditionnée d'être la
transparence sur les le financement à
des explications claires sur les
principes la république il est clair que
dans cette affaire darmanin fait de
l'instrumentalisation politique
vergne encore les élus municipaux tous
confondus disait que ce point ne posait
pas de problème est qu'ils ne
souhaitaient même pas on laboure dans
des mains en séance publique
parce qu'il semblait évident qu'il
serait validé automatiquement d'accord
donc pour vous il n'y a pas de problème
sur sur cette mosquée de stratégie entre
emblème que l'association soit dissoute
mais pour ça il faut des arguments
sérieux
merci beaucoup jacques fernique pour
votre réaction
et on va maintenant aller dans la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle pour
voir avec vous ce team quel va être le
programme de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
eh bien on parlera coville locaux vides
qui sera à nouveau le fil rouge en
quelque sorte de cette séance
d'actualité au gouvernement et sur la
question bien des conséquences
économiques et surtout sociale des
annonces du gouvernement la semaine
dernière de l' annonce d'un nouveau
confinement puisqu'il faut le rappeler
le confinement c'est aussi et peut-être
surtout la fermeture des petits
commerces 90000 90000 commerce jugés non
essentiels ont dû et bien fermé leurs
portes les sénateurs vont interpeller le
gouvernement sur la nécessité de
maintenir voire d'amplifier les aides
économiques à destination de ces petits
commerces et puis il sort aussi question
cet après midi d'un éventuel nouveau
report des élections régionales et
départementales
un report de ces élections qui aurait dû
se tenir le week-end dernier et qui ont
été déjà reportée au mois de juin
prochain est ce que c'est bien ces
élections pourront se tenir au regard
notamment de l'évolution inquiétante des
chiffres de l'épidémie le gouvernement
sera interrogé à ce sujet dans quelques
instants la séance l'homme des buts et
on se retrouve juste après pour un
débrief
y'en a t'il en séance
je n'en vois point il est donc adoptée
sous les réserves visage monsieur le
premier ministre et des messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues l'ordre du
jour appelle les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
une autre séance est retransmise en
direct sur public sénat et notre site
internet ce qu'un respectera son temps
se respectera les uns les autres et nous
serons attentifs aussi à l'ensemble des
gestes prophylactique en cette période
donc ceci me semble important je vais
donner si vous le voulez bien la parole
à notre collecte animaux aiment être
solide pour le groupe
le rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mais ce premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues hier l'épidémie de la
copie 19 cause et 292 décès
supplémentaires nous rapprocher encore
davantage de la bague redouté des cent
mille morts mes pensées vont aux
familles endeuillées et aux soignants
épuisé maintenant après le virus est
toujours là mais la résilience des
citoyens la force de nos professionnels
de santé et l'engagement des élus
s'efforcent de lui faire face
le premier ministre a ainsi annoncé des
mesures spécifiques dans seize
départements la semaine dernière
nécessaires pour répondre aux appels des
professionnels de santé submergé
nécessaire aussi pour nous adapter à ce
virus qui mute et nous impose de
modifier nos certitudes mais les mesures
de l'année passée ne sont pas celles
d'aujourd'hui et ne seront probablement
pas celle de demain
elles peuvent dorénavant être
territorialisée commun mayotte et variés
pour répondre sanitaires sans oublier la
santé mentale
un an après la cage vide rythme encore
nos journées mais une certitude est
aujourd'hui acquise la vaccination sur
tout le territoire en hexagone comme en
outre-mer est notre unique issue en un
an les scientifiques ont réalisé des
prouesses suspendant le recherche pour
se concentrer sur un seul virus afin de
développer des vaccins au taux
d'efficacité inégalée désormais la
vaccination de près de 91% des résidents
en ehpad ou sld
à terme est de diminuer sensiblement les
hospitalisations de ces populations
la vaccination fonctionne nous pouvons
nous en réjouir pour autant encore trop
de personnes âgées ne parviennent pas à
trouver de place pour se protéger et la
confiance vis-à-vis de certains vaccins
continue à être ébranlée par quelques
cas isolés mais inquiétant monsieur le
ministre
alors que la fatigue prend de plus en
plus le pas sur la résilience
les citoyens ont besoin d'un horizon
clair vers une sortie de crise quelles
perspectives pouvez-nous pouvez vous
nous apportez pour assurer la
vaccination sécurisé de tous les
français qui le souhaitent dans
l'ensemble du territoire pour vous
répondre la parole et au secrétaire
d'état en charge de l'enfance et des
familles monsieur le drian tacle parole
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur thani mohamed
soilihi vous êtes vous avez commencé par
l'essentiel et j'ai envie de commencer
moi aussi par mme associé à l'hommage
que vous rendez aux dizaines de milliers
de familles endeuillées et aux soignants
évidemment mobilisé depuis maintenant
plus d'un an sur cette crise qui met
notre notre système de santé à l'épreuve
nous saluons à nouveau leur dévouement
et la résilience que vous avez évoqué de
l'ensemble de nos de nos compatriotes
face à cette situation changeante que le
gouvernement adapte sa stratégie en
concertation avec l'ensemble des acteurs
notamment avec les élus locaux avec pour
seul objectif de rester le plus efficace
dans cette lutte contre l'épidémie et de
prendre les bons mesure au bon moment et
vous avez justement noté que ces mesures
sont de plus en plus territorialisées
car si le taux d'incidence et la
pression hospitalières sont sont très
élevées à certains endroits du
territoire nous pensons évidemment à
l'île de france aux hautes france ce
n'est malheureusement pas le cas dans
toutes nos régions nous avons choisi de
prendre des mesures de freinage forte
dans seize départements à ce stade
peut-être dans deux départements le
premier ministre y reviendra peut-être
tout à l'heure où la situation est
critique et les quatre semaines pour
lesquels ont été décidées ces mesures
sont sont déterminantes vous le savez
tout cela s'articule avec l'effort de
vaccination que nous souhaitons tous
voir s'intensifier les vaccins sont le
le principal espoir de sortie de crise
évidemment nous le répétons sans cesse
il faut vacciner il faut se faire
vacciner
cela vaut pour l'autre mais rêver
cela vaut pour mayotte où 75% des doses
livrées ont été inoculés mais il faut
accélérer la mobilisation de tous doit
être totale notamment celles des élus
locaux et je salue votre engagement
monsieur le sénateur à cet égard nos
objectifs restent inchangés vacciner 10
millions de français la mi-avril 20
millions à l'ami même et le président de
la république pour ce faire a annoncé
hier vous l'avez entendu que dès samedi
la vaccination sera élargi aux plus de
70 ans sans comorbidités que pour
n'oublier personne l'assurance maladie
va appeler tous les plus de 75 ans qui
ne sont pas encore vaccinés afin de leur
proposer un créneau que des campagnes de
vaccination ciblée seront enfin bientôt
lancer en lien avec l'arrivée des
nouvelles doses puisque évidemment tout
dépend de la disponibilité de l'arrivée
des doses de vaccin je pense également à
l'ouverture rapide de 35 vaccinodromes
concertation a lieu en ce moment avec
les élus locaux pour déterminer les
lieux et la répartition qui permettra
d'optimiser la répartition des doses
dont les arrivées vont augmenter à
compter de mi-avril notamment dans les
autres mers d'optimiser aussi la façon
dont les professionnels de santé seront
mobilisés ce que vous savez que nous
allons également mobilisé l'armée pour
accélérer cette phase de vaccination
voilà monsieur le sénateur pour ces
éléments vous donner la parole notre
collègue michael fallait pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur ministre de
l'intérieur visiblement représentée par
madame la ministre déléguée et elle
porte sur la continuité de notre vie
démocratique il y a un an jour pour jour
la france entrer à nouveau dans l'état
d'urgence la soudaineté du premier
confinement a pleinement justifié les
difficultés d'organisation des élections
municipales mais un état d'urgence
par définition vise à répondre aux
urgences il ne doit pas affecter de
façon déraisonnable des rendez vous
démocratique planifié de longue date la
loi du 22 février 2021 reportant de mars
à juin les élections départementales et
régionales notamment prévoit une clause
de revoyure au 1er avril après avis du
conseil scientifique
mais ne nous y trompons pas le conseil
scientifique rendra un avis qui sera
fonction des moyens et des innovations
mises en oeuvre pour permettre le bon
déroulement de ces élections
ma question est simple madame la
ministre
quelles propositions d'organisation de
notre vie démocratique
pouvez-vous mettre en avant pour
faciliter une réponse positive du
conseil scientifique à la tenue de ce
temps fort de notre démocratie dont vous
répondre la parole milices délayer la
parole merci monsieur le président
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames les
sénatrices et monsieur le sénateur
michael valait moi je voudrais vous
répondre très clairement la question que
vous posez d'autant plus clairement que
j'ai eu le plaisir et l'honneur de
représenter le gouvernement ici même
pendant plusieurs heures quand nous
avons débattu ensemble de la question de
la date des élections départementales et
des élections régionales et le sénat
comme l'assemblée nationale ont acté le
fait dans cette fois de report que très
simplement ces élections se tiennent le
13 et le 20 juin prochain le
gouvernement comme il s'y était engagé à
d'ailleurs immédiatement aux dés le mois
de mars passé le décret de convocation
des électeurs pour le 13 et le 20 juin
prochain dans cette loi que vous avez
dit ce que nous avons discuté et que
vous avez voté il est également fait
mention du rapport du rapport du conseil
scientifique ce rapport il doit être
présenté et transmis par le gouvernement
au parlement avant le 1er avril à date
nul ne dispose du contenu du rapport du
conseil scientifique mais au final c'est
bien le parlement qui aura le
dernier mot puisque en fonction des
résultats de ce rapport n'est dans le
parlement sera amené à se prononcer une
fois qu'il en aura eu connaissance
moi je veux dire très simplement au nom
du gouvernement de jean castex que nous
nous souhaitons que les élections
régionales à ce stade puissent maintenir
le 13 et le 20 juin comme cela a été
voté par le parlement et d'ailleurs avec
gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur auprès de qui
je suis rattaché nous travaillons
ensemble avec les maires avec les
collectivités pour un protocole
sanitaires strictes qui répondent à
toutes les mesures que vous avez voté
notamment la mutualisation des fonctions
d'assesseur les présidents de bureaux de
vote pour faire en sorte que la
démocratie continue et que ces élections
régionales se tiennent bien le 13 et le
20 juin prochain ainsi que les élections
départementales le 13 et le 20 juin
prochain
et c'est pourquoi des bureaux de vote
seront mutualisés pour que les deux
scrutins puisse bien avoir lieu le 13 et
le 20 juin prochain je vous remercie
monsieur mickaël vallet vous avez la
parole
j'entends bien madame la ministre que
les élections doivent se tenir quoi
qu'il en coûte selon l'expression
consacrée
ces six derniers mois pour ne citer que
ces pays là l'allemagne les états unis
le kosovo la côte d'ivoire la suisse le
niger et 50 autres états ont tous fait
en sorte que les élections se tiennent
mais la cinquième puissance mondiale en
est encore à demeurer dans le doute
à trois mois du scrutin ces six derniers
mois également sur les différents bancs
du sénat ont été proposés la double
procuration le vote par correspondance
l'étalement du vote sur trois jours et
j'en passe mais le gouvernement a rejeté
toutes ces propositions d'innovation
démocratique qui valait pourtant bien
les grands débats de 2019 et la
convention citoyenne de 2020 la démo
racle la démocratie aurait gagné à ce
que vous saisissiez ces propositions du
sénat est sur le bon déroulement des
élections
chacun devra assumer et ne pas rejeter
sur d'autres ses responsabilités car le
sénat en faisant ces propositions lui a
déjà pris les siennes mais
c'est la parole est maintenant aux
présidents jean claude requier pour le
gros du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
lors de la réunion du mercredi 17 mars
du comité de liaison parlementaire pour
la gestion de la crise sanitaire qui a
rassemblé soit présidence plusieurs
ministres le président du sénat et les
prési dent du groupe de haute assemblée
vous aideront à mener au nom du groupe
rdse de retarder le début du couvre feu
de 18h à 20h à raison de l'allongement
de la durée du jour et de l'arrivée de
l'arrêter vous m'avez répondu que l'inde
était posé problème et va lancer le
lendemain le déclara du couvre-feu de
18h à 19h faisant ainsi gagner une heure
deux jours de lumière et de liberté à
nos concitoyens et j'aimerais vous
remercier pour les 16 départements les
plus touchés par la pandémie
il avait ensuite annoncé une troisième
variable de ses consignes au mieux
troisième voie un décor finalement moins
de confiner toujours vigilant des sas
privé mais plus larges espaces publics
permettra aux habitants de se déplacer
davantage que lors des précédentes
confinement mais c'était sans compter
samedi sur la fameuse attestation de
dérogatoire de dopage avec 15 mo ti de
déplacement retenue et 3 limite fixée à
1 d'ici 30 km attestation aussitôt
qualifié des chefs-d'oeuvre
bureaucratique qu'on allait supprimer le
lendemain puis ressortir version
simplifiée
cette complexité et ses excellents
contribuer à regarder la morosité la
lassitude et la fatigue concitoyens à
rude épreuve depuis un an
monsieur le ministre en cas
d'aggravation de la pandémie quelle
mesure envisagez vous de prendre dans
les 16 départements de la zone rouge
estaing ceux de la zone verte on vous
répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur présent et qui est
merci tout d'abord d'avoir rappelé au
sénat lé processus de concertation que
j'organise de manière régulière avec les
présidents des différents groupes ici
représentés comme du reste
vos collègues de l'assemblée nationale
avant que nous ne prenions des
dispositions merci également d'avoir
observé que contrairement à ce que je
peux entendre ici ou là ces
concertations sont des exercices
extrêmement utile et que j'en tiens le
plus grand compte vous venez en
particulier d'y faire référence
s'agissant notamment de l'heure du
couvre-feu et les arguments que vous
avez alors invoqué notamment liée au
passage de l'heure d'été étant
parfaitement pertinent en réponse à
votre question
monsieur président bayle nous allons
continuer dans cette stratégie qui est
d'abord territorialisée je le rappelle
parce que là aussi monsieur le président
c'était une demande régulièrement
exprimée en particulier par le sénat
mais je dois dire ici que nous
maintiendrons cette stratégie autant que
cela sera possible
il n'a échappé à personne ici sur aucun
banc de cette assemblée que nous sommes
face à une troisième vague
particulièrement virulente
particulièrement virulente vous regardez
toutes et tous
toutes et tous je sais que vous aimez
regarder ou paix dans les pays étrangers
en allemagne en italie bien
alors posons les choses une troisième
vague extrêmement importante qui nous
conduit à prendre des mesures
territorialisée et de freinage est plus
adapté possible mais oui monsieur le
sénateur que nous pouvions être conduits
à durcir en fonction de l'évolution de
la pandémie
nous avons un devoir de nous adapter
comme nous l'avons toujours fait comme
nous l'avons toujours fait nous tenons
compte aussi de ce que nous avons appris
l'année dernière
et lors des mesures de freinage
antérieur effectivement le retour
d'expérience le retour d'expérience
accepté que je vous réponde montre que
les lieux de contamination clos sont
beaucoup plus dangereux que l'espace
extérieur et donc et donc nous avons
intégré cette considération dans les
mesures prises
ce qui ne signifie pas je le dis de
façon très solennelle devant le sénat
qu'à l'extérieur on puisse faire
n'importe quoi et nous avons mais c'est
l'objet de l'attestation clairement
défini clairement défini ce qu'il est
possible de faire et ce qu'il n'est pas
possible de faire je vous remercie
monsieur président roch et oui dans cet
écrit ce monsieur le président
continuait associés et à faire confiance
aux élus locaux
et puis pour rédiger une attestation
simple fonctionnel est applicable
vous pourriez peut-être de m'amener un
avis inverse expérimenté un conseiller
le var deux alsh aux chevronnés ou
peut-être à un sénateur
la parole est à notre collègue sophie
taillé et poli ans pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire donné
la parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation auquel je
voudrais faire part de remontées de
terrain de par les propos tenus par des
responsables de l'académie de créteil
je cite il y a eu un véritable tsunami
de remonter de cas positifs par les
écoles à traiter cette dernière semaine
tous les médecins de l'éducation
nationale du département sont sur le
pont mais compte tenu du nombre très
important de cas il n'est pas possible
de répondre dans des délais
satisfaisants et un médecin du val de
marne le confirme il y à plus de 600
situation où il y a des retard
c'est-à-dire autant d'écoles que dans le
département pour traiter les demandes
qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya des cas
positifs la réalité du terrain elle est
là et dans les écoles aujourd'hui vous
êtes débordé il n'y a pas de réponse
dans les temps pour décider des
éventuelles fermetures ou pour mettre en
oeuvre avec rigueur le tester isolé
tracé cela génère confusion mauvaise
décision il n'y a pas de remplaçants en
nombre suffisant donc on mélange les
élèves pour poursuivre l'accueil au
mépris du protocole sanitaire
il n'y a pas de moyens de protection des
personnels enseignants ou éducatif
on parle d'un vaccin on le demande mais
déjà donné leur des masques ils n'ont
pas été remplacés depuis septembre et ce
sont des masques en tissu qui ne sont
même pas de catégorie 1
il n'y a pas de réponse pour les
collèges qui demandent à faire des
rotations comme les lycées pour limiter
l'accès à la restauration scolaire
il n'ya enfin pas d'utilisation pour
anticiper quitte à les prolonger un peu
les prochaines vacances alphin qu'elle
soit l'occasion d'un moment de freinage
puissant
je vous le demande madame la ministre
nous voulons garder avec vous les écoles
ouvertes mais pas n'importe comment
il faut maintenant prendre des mesures
fortes pour que la situation revienne
sous contrôle on vous répond on a parlé
qu'à la secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'éducation
l'image laminée
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice en cette période si
particulière nous avons une double
responsabilité
la première c'est d'assurer la
protection de nos élèves et de nos
personnels la deuxième c'est de garantir
la réussite scolaire pour la protection
de nos élèves et de nos personnels je
vous rappelle le déploiement de nos
protocoles sanitaires que nous ne
cessons d'adapter vous avez évoqué
madame la sénatrice la question des
remplacements et bien si il y à des
remplaçants dans nos écoles 2200 ont été
affectés dans le premier degré 2700 à ed
dans le second degré nous déployons
également des tests antigénique et
salivaires 320000 test proposé 200 mille
tests réalisés avec un taux de
positivité dans nos établissements qui
oscille entre 0 3 et 0 5%
je les dis aussi garantir la réussite de
nos élèves avec jean michel blanquer
l'ensemble du gouvernement nous avons
une conviction
l'école c'est important et c'est bon
pour nos élèves c'est important
notamment pour les plus fragiles d'entre
eux il faut lutter avec eux contre le
décrochage scolaire
c'est bon pour nos élèves nous allons
nous il suffit de regarder madame la
sénatrice le résultat des évaluations
nationales et de comparer les résultats
de septembre et les résultats de janvier
et c'est parce que nos écoles sont
ouvertes c'est parce qu'il ya cette
exception française cette fierté
française que nous avons rattrapé les
écarts et que nous avons résorbé l'écart
qu'il y avait entre l'éducation
prioritaire et le hors éducation
prioritaire
le président de la république a annoncé
hier l'élargissement de la politique
vaccinale et notamment le déploiement
d'une campagne ciblée et bien madame la
sénatrice nos professeurs devront comme
cela a été dit hier par le président de
la république pourront en bénéficier
d'ici quelques semaines jour merci
maintenant taille et pau lyon
premièrement madame la ministre
il n'y a pas que les professeurs il ya
toute la communauté éducative à vacciner
tous les personnels qui interviennent et
je voulais le dire
deuxièmement malin pour les remplaçants
à l'école des hauts de bruyères à
villejuif les parents étaient obligés de
se mobiliser et de menacer voire même
d'occuper l'école
si vous pensez que c'est à la hauteur eh
bien je crois que vous êtes vraiment en
dessous il faut des moyens
supplémentaires et notamment en
remplaçant pour qu'on arrête de brasser
les élèves ainsi la parole et à notre
collègue franck non ville pour le groupe
les indépendants république et
territoires
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'agriculture
elle porte sur les difficultés
actuellement dans la filière viande
bovine dans notre pays
en effet en 2020 alors même que les
ventes de viande bovine française en
progrès c'est le prix payé aux éleveurs
n'a cessé lui de chuter pour aboutir à
un résultat particulièrement alarmant
car selon la fédération nationale bovine
en effet les éleveurs ont dû vivre avec
moins de 700 euros par mois cette année
la france est pourtant le premier
producteur européen de viande bovine
avec 485 milles emplois qui contribuent
à l'animation nos territoires et
façonnent nos paysages
la viande rouge représente 63% de la
viande consommée en france et fait
partie intégrante de notre patrimoine
gastronomique
alors nous ne pouvons pas regarder sans
agir nos éleveurs disparaître en raison
de prix inexplicablement bas à l'image
du cours des jeunes bovins nous ne
pouvons pas laisser les éleveurs
continuent à vendre leurs animaux à un
prix inférieur d'environ 1 heureux un
euro du kilo par rapport au coût de
production des coûts de production qui
d'ailleurs cesse d'augmenter la crise
des éleveurs est accentuée par
l'augmentation des prix des matières
premières nécessaires à l'alimentation
du bétail ravivant ainsi les tensions
deux sur la b le partage de la valeur
ajoutée la loi et galim porteuse
d'espoir sens et rééquilibrer les
relations commerciales entre
agriculteurs transformateurs grande
distribution tarde à porter ses fruits
en pleines négociations de la pac les
inquiétudes se font grande
alors monsieur le ministre que comptez
vous faire pour soutenir concrètement et
dans la durée les éleveurs français pour
lire leur redonner de nouvelles
perspectives et au delà des aides
annoncées les éleveurs ont besoin de
soutien structurel et quelles mesures
comptez vous prendre pour rendre la
halle la loi et galim efficiente face
aux réalités de nos éleveurs français
pour vous répondre la parole de tommy
lee de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur julien de
normandie où monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur votre question porte sur la loi
et délits mais sur cette juste
rémunération de nos agriculteurs
moi je vais vous parlé avec beaucoup de
franchise
la situation aujourd'hui elle reste
inacceptable la loi et galim elle a
permis de faire des bouger mais force
est de constater que certains parmi la
grande distribution parmi les
industriels ne respecte ni l'esprit ni
parfois même la lettre de la loi et
galim est la conséquence c'est quoi
c'est que d'un côté on ne peut pas
demander à notre agriculture qui a
chevillé au corps cette volonté de
nourrir le peuple on ne peut pas lui
demander de toujours nourrir avec plus
de qualité
si au même moment on laisse s'organiser
cette guerre des prix on voit bien
monter en qualité tout en faisant cette
guerre des prix
c'est incompatible alors face à ça il
nous faut faire deux choses
la fermeté est allée plus loin sur la
loi et galim d'abord la fermeté les
négociations commerciales c'est un
rapport de force je l' ai toujours dit
l'état est rentré dans ce rapport de
force
songez monsieur le sénateur qu'en
l'espace de six semaines nous avons fait
l'équivalent de six mois de contrôles
parce que dans notre république la loi
elle doit être appliquée et donc avec la
dgccrf on a démultiplié les contrôles
mais au-delà de ce rapport de force il
nous faut aller plus loin sur la loi et
galim il nous faut comprendre ce qui ne
marche pas et voir qu'est-ce qu'il nous
faut modifier
c'est tout le sens des travaux que j'ai
confiée à serge papin l'ancien président
de système u qui me remet ses
recommandations demain et qui vise à
quoi à faire
plus de contractualisation à faire plus
de transparence et au final à trouver
des solutions
sûrement législatives d'ailleurs pour
arrêter cette contradiction entre la loi
lme de 2007 que vous connaissez bien qui
était une loi de déflation et la loi et
galine qui vise à mieux rémunérés mais
l'une et l'autre là aussi nécessite
d'être beaucoup mieux coordonner et donc
il nous faudra faire à nouveau débouché
des bouger là dessus je m'y engage
sous l'autorité du premier ministre
c'est une question de souveraineté
merci la parole et notre collègue jérôme
bascher pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues en fin de semaine dernière la
présidente de l'unef a avoué organiser
des réunions réservées aux personnes de
couleur
l'unef a donc désormais comme critère la
couleur de peau dans des régions dites
racisées pas raciste racisées hélas ce
syndicat n'en est pas un coup d'essai en
2019 il a tenté d'empêcher une
représentation de la pièce d'eschyle ou
encore à considérer l'émotion ressentie
par les français lors de l' incendie
dramatique de notre dame de paris
comme je cite un délire de petits blancs
on pourra parler aussi de la récente
affaire de l'iep de grenoble aujourd'hui
l'arsenal juridique français permet de
sanctionner toutes les formes de
discrimination particulièrement
lorsqu'elles se fonde sur l'origine et
la couleur de peau
le délit de provocation à la
discrimination existe pourquoi ne
faites-vous pas référence
qu'attendez vous pour simplement appelé
à l'application de la loi pénale comme
vient de le rappeler monsieur d'armandie
au delà de l'action judiciaire
chaque année l'unef perçoit une
subvention de 600 mille euros de l'état
alors l'état doit-il continuer à
financer l'organisation de réunions
précisé on vous répondre la parole est à
madame la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et de
l'innovation
non merci monsieur le président mesdames
et sénatrices et sénateurs monsieur
sénateur bailly cher will et les
réunions que vous avez mentionnés sont
inacceptables et oui bien sûr je les
condamne
pourquoi est-ce qu'elles sont
inacceptables d'abord parce qu elles
trahissent ses valeurs fondamentales de
notre république
des valeurs que évidemment nous
défendons tous ici une valeur longtemps
défendu d'ailleurs par l'unef
elle même c'est l'universalisme et je
regrette bien sûr qu'une partie de la
nef semble manifestement s'en éloigner
au travers de ces réunions regrettable
aussi car contraire à l'objectif même
qu'elles prétendent défendre la lutte
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme
mais la lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et je suis sûr que nous
en serons tous d'accord c'est la sphère
de tous alors oui je condamne et oui je
regrette qu'au moins une partie des
membres de l'unef cède à ces dérives
vous savez comme moi probablement que
ces réunions se tenait apparemment à
l'extérieur des universités apparemment
dans une sphère privée et vous savez et
vous savez comme moi que il est facile
d'en appeler à la loi mais que je crois
que le terrain sur lequel nous devons
nous placer avant toute chose c'est
vraiment le terrain des valeurs et nous
devons demander à l'unef de clarifier
ses positions et ses valeurs ce sont les
étudiants qui jugent de cela et ils le
feront notamment dans les urnes
nous avons besoin de corps
intermédiaires lunettes
fait aujourd'hui la deuxième
organisation représentative des
étudiants en france et nous devons donc
nous préoccuper des valeurs que l'unef
porte
nous avons besoin de l'engagement de
tous les étudiants pour porter des
solutions nous avons besoin de corps
intermédiaires pour définir avec quelles
solutions sur les meilleurs mais nous
devons aussi leur rappeler que
l'universalisme n'est pas réservé aux
livres d'histoire
c'est une valeur moderne utile exigeante
une valeur qui fait la grandeur de notre
nation mais aussi monsieur vaches r oui
déjà il ya trois ans j'ai interrogé le
gouvernement sur la candidate
vice-présidente voilée de l'unef et le
gouvernement à l'époque avait répondu
qu'il ferait tout pour les valeurs de la
république
alors soit vous n'avez rien fait soit
votre discours performatif est tout
aussi efficace que pour la lutte contre
le coc vide comme dirait le vis de
l'intérieur votre réponse est un peu
molle les 600000 euros vous n'y avez pas
répondu d'actions judiciaires vous n'y
avez pas répondu
alors l'unef est aujourd'hui à l'opposé
de ce que portent les valeurs françaises
ne laissons pas le pire du monde anglo
saxon nous envahir
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est notre collègue n'a pas
reflété notre collègue olivier cadic
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'europe et des affaires
étrangères petite frappe ya une furieuse
voilà le langage fleuri utilisé par
l'ambassade de chine pour qualifier le
chercheur antoine bon daz à la suite de
son rapport taiwan une puissance
diplomatique à part entière
parallèlement cette ambassade a adressé
une lettre à notre groupe sénatorial
d'études et de contacts avec taïwan
l'ambassadeur de chine louchart s'oppose
fermement au déplacement de sénateurs
français à taiwan
il a menacé ensuite ceux qui s'y
rendrait
comme l'an dernier suite à des outrances
similaire vous avez à nouveau convoqué
ce triste diplomate dont les saillies
donne une bien piteuse image de la chine
le grand pays avec lequel nous aimerions
avoir d'autres relations
vous avez eu raison d'agir avec fermeté
la france et le sénat ne reçoivent pas
de consignes du parti communiste chinois
pour mener avec succès le combat
idéologique majeur qui nous oppose à la
chine
l'europe ne peut être ne peut qu'être
unis nous disiez vous en octobre dernier
grâce aux médias
le monde découvre peu à peu avec effroi
l'emprise de la dictature du régime de
pékin sur tout le peuple chinois avec
l'aide des nouvelles technologies lundi
pour la première fois depuis la
répression de tiananmen
l'union européenne a imposé des
sanctions contre des chinois ayant
commis des graves atteintes aux droits
de l'homme et chen chang contre la
minorité musulmane ouïghoure
en réponse la chine sanctionne dix
parlementaires européens et des entités
de l'union européenne lors de votre
réunion d'hier avec vos homologues
européens à bruxelles
avez vous envisagé de prendre de
nouvelles dispositions vis-à-vis de
pékin
et pensez vous que les conditions sont
réunies pour ratifier l'accord
commercial de l'union européenne avec la
chine
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au ministre délégué en
charge du commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité monsieur franck riester
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur olivier cadic jean
yves le drian et est retenu dans le
cadre de réunions au sein de l'otan
s'agissant de l'ambasseur de
l'ambassadeur de chine
monsieur le sénateur comme vous et comme
tous nos concitoyens
j'ai été profondément choqué par ses
récents propos et sa conduite
je rappelle devant vous l'évidence les
parlementaires français décident
librement de leurs projets de
déplacements et de leurs contacts
ces propos inacceptables de
l'ambassadeur ont valu à monsieur
louchats y ait une convocation au hier
matin comme vous l'avez rappelé au
ministère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères il a été sommé de prendre la
mesure de la gravité de la situation
mais polémique publique les tentatives
d'intimidation l'insulté et l'invectivé
contre les yeux de la république les
institutions académiques les chercheurs
les médias et plus largement la société
civile
tout cela n'est pas tolérable dans notre
république est là absolument pas sa
place dans les relations entre la france
et la chine
s'agissant des mesures annoncées par la
chine en réponse aux sanctions
européennes auquel vous avez fait
référence à l'encontre notamment des
membres des parlements européens ou
nationaux comme le député européen
raphaël glucksmann de chercheurs et de
diplomates
nous les avons fort fermement et
fortement condamné j'en profite pour
souligner comme vous l'avez fait que
c'est la première fois depuis trente ans
que l'union européenne adopte des
sanctions à l'encontre de la chine
c'est une décision historique légitime
et nécessaire
il a été solennellement demandé à
l'ambassadeur de chine de rapporter à
pékin que ce n'est pas en attaquant ceux
qui ont dénoncé les violations commises
ni en s'en prenant la liberté académique
à la liberté d'expression et aux
libertés démocratiques fondamentales que
la chine répondra aux préoccupations
légitimes exprimées sur la situation des
droits de l'homme aussi mme jean
s'agissant de nos relations commerciales
la chine est un partenaire économique
incontournable à l'échelle mondiale mais
nos relations ne doivent pas se faire au
détriment de nos principes de nos
valeurs et du modèle de société que nous
défendons ni être exempt
de réciprocité en ce qui concerne
spécifiquement l'accord d'investissement
entre l'union et la chine
nous considérons que les derniers
développements graves notamment les
sanctions contre les parlementaires
européens nous conforte notre vote dans
notre volonté d'être très fermes sur nos
exigences notamment sur le travail forcé
dans les discussions à venir sur k dick
merci beaucoup pour votre réponse
monsieur le ministre dans son communiqué
le ministère chinois des affaires
étrangères a annoncé que les dix
ressortissants de l'union européenne
sanctionné et leurs familles sont
dorénavant interdits d'entrer dans la
partie continentale de la chine
les régions administratives spéciales de
hong kong et macao en omettant de citer
taïwan
tout le monde peut constater la
reconnaissance implicite par pékin de la
souveraineté de taiwan sur son
territoire rien ne devrait donc plus
opposés à ce que taiwan sillage l oms et
interpol
[Applaudissements]
sa part l'été le ferez collègue pascal
savoldelli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologie s'il a
deux minutes
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le 4 juin dernier le sénat a rejeté la
proposition de loi que nous avions
déposé avec mon collègue fabien gay et
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologique portant sur le statut des
travailleurs des plateformes numériques
de travail
ce texte cette proposition de loi visait
à appliquer le droit social à la
relation de travail
unissant ces plateformes telles qu
hubert ou délits verrous et leurs
travailleurs dits indépendants
pourtant schumi à leur management
algorithmique l'intégration dans livres
7 du code du travail que nous proposions
leur permettait d'accéder à la
protection du salariat tout en
renforçant la demande d'une autonomie
collective je parle bien d'autonomie et
pas d'indépendance en faveur des
travailleurs en dépit de notre main
tendue à votre gouvernement et à tous
les groupes de cette assemblée
la droite a voté contre et le groupe
socialiste s'est abstenu
pourtant les différentes décisions de
justice qui se multiplient en europe
nous donne raison
les pays-bas l'italie l'espagne les
royaume uni et même la france
tout confirme notre position la
requalification en salariat fait foi je
vous demande monsieur le ministre
allez vous enfin confirmé le statut de
salarié de ces travailleurs quand vous
répondre la parole mais pour ce facteur
d'état chargé des retraites et la santé
au travail
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur savoldelli bondé
plateforme de mise en relation offre
c'est vrai des possibilités d'emploi et
d'autre part des services qui sont de
plus en plus utilisée est demandée par
nos concitoyens ces dernières années en
cette période de crise sanitaire
d'ailleurs vous le sel permettent aux
restaurateurs de développer massivement
leurs offres de livraison à domicile ce
qui peut compenser pour partie les
difficultés auxquelles
ils font face dans cette crise sanitaire
est cependant nécessaire que ces
nouvelles formes d'emploi ne se
développe pas au détriment des
conditions de travail et de rémunération
des travailleurs indépendants qui ont
recours le gouvernement est convaincu
j'ai envie de dire comme vous et sans
doute comme l'immense majorité des
sénateurs que seul un dialogue structuré
entre les plateformes et représentants
légitimes
ces travailleurs indépendants du plate
forme permettra de rééquilibrer la
relation commerciale en faveur de
meilleures conditions de travail la loi
d'orientation des mobilités habilite le
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnance
sur les modalités de représentation des
travailleurs indépendants ou des
plateformes les conditions d'exercice de
cette représentation
le premier ministre a chargé l'ancien
président de la chambre sociale de la
cour de cassation genre et foin d'une
mission visant à préciser ses modalités
de représentation
son rapport a été remis en décembre de
l'année dernière et il avait le borgne a
par la suite confié à trois
personnalités qualifiées la
responsabilité de mener des travaux de
rédaction du projet d'ordonnancé en
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux et représentants des plateformes
les travailleurs indépendants des
plateformes
ces travaux ont été menés en tout début
d'année les préconisations présentées au
groupe des partenaires sociaux le 12
mars
voyez nous avançons le projet
d'ordonnancé sera prochainement soumis à
l'examen du conseil d'état en vue d'une
adoption en conseil des ministres au
mois d'avril
son ambition est de rendre effective la
représentation et donc permettre le
dialogue social dans la durée de ces
travailleurs de plateformes je crois
monsieur le sénateur que nous pourrions
au moins de retrouver sur cet objectif
de représentativité de discussion
équilibrée au sein de ce nouveau type
d'entreprise merci monsieur chat
moldavie oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur me voyais pas répondu vous avez
parlé de rééquilibrer les relations
commerciales et vous me parlez d une
ordonnance sur le dialogue social moi je
vous parle du code du travail pour les
livreurs des plateformes
c'est ça dont je vous parle et pas
d'autres choses
et rappelez vous ici ayez un peu de
conséquence vous les avez vu vous les
livreurs qui livrent des burgers et qui
se retrouvent après aller chercher à
manger à s'alimenter
c'est sa libéralisation de la société
que vous voulez vous méprisez toutes les
décisions de justice de par l'europe
vous écoutez pas nos propositions et
vous nous vendez une sorte d'auto
satisfaction avec une moralité là avec
des usines à gaz de texte etc
heureusement qu'en politique et du
courage et de la volonté et jaurès à lui
et moi la ministre espagnole madame
yolande gasquet communistes ils ont
décidé d'aller vers un statut du
salariat et wii et wii et wii et wii et
wii et ses propositions elles ont été
tranchées mais copuler la forme d'autre
le droit du travail pour les
travailleurs des plateformes
merci
[Musique]
la parole est à madame la présidente
pascale gruny pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresser à monsieur le ministre
délégué chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises
monsieur le ministre fermetures
ouvertures fermetures les commerçants
voient vos décisions se succéder comme
autant de coups de massue ils n'en
peuvent plus plus de réserves plus de
fonds propres
ils ont des stocks sur les bras et leurs
fournisseurs et leurs banques sur le dos
leur colère monte les produits de
première nécessité finalement c'est quoi
le choix devient absurde
comment expliquer un petit commerçant
qui respecte les gestes barrières et qui
accueille ses clients les uns après les
autres et plus contaminant qu'un magasin
de bricolage
comment expliquer une esthéticienne
qu'elle doit fermer son salon de beauté
quand le coiffeur a eu droit d'ouvrir
les commerçants comme les français sont
prêts à faire des efforts mais le
gouvernement doit leur parler clairement
si non quel sens donner à leur sacrifice
vos décisions doivent être logique et
surtout équitable nous vous attendons
aussi sur les oubliés du fonds de
solidarité
pourquoi les entrepreneurs qui ont
repris un fonds de commerce existence au
statut holding n'ont ils aucune aide
pourquoi les bar épicerie n'ont ils pas
une indemnisation suffisante
vous avez été saisis de plusieurs
questions sur ce fonds d'indemnisation
il y a plusieurs mois et on attend les
réponses et c'est urgent ou ce sera le
dépôt de bilan
je vous remercie pour vous répondre
d'abord le communiste délégué en charge
des comptes publics monsieur du soap
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la présidente de greny quelques
mots pour répondre à votre question
d'abord en soulignant que les
restrictions d'ouverture les obligations
de fermeture pourrait être plus
explicite qui s'impose aux commerçants
sont des obligations que nous retrouvons
dans la plupart des pays européens et sa
distinction nous trouvons entre les
commerces que l'on qualifie parfois
d'essentiel ou non les commerces de
première nécessité ou non si j'ai
presque envie de vous dire peu importe
le vocabulaire répondre uniquement à des
préoccupations sanitaires
derrière ces décisions il n'y a nulle
volonté de stigmatiser une catégorie de
commerçants plutôt qu'une autre
une volonté de favoriser une catégorie
de commerçants plutôt qu'une autre il
est la volonté de freiner l'épidémie est
le premier ministre à l'occasion d'y
revenir régulièrement ce qui me
permettra de venir directement sur la
question de l'indemnisation
le fonds solidarité nous avons mis en
place au mois de mars 2020 a d'ores et
déjà accompagné deux millions
d'entreprises et à date nous avons des
questions 20 milliards d'euros de
soutien auprès des entreprises nous
sommes là aussi le pays européen qui
indemnise le plus fortement les
indépendants les commerçants et les
entreprises fermées et c'est une fierté
que nous devons revendiquer car nous
devons nous avons le devoir de les
accompagner
le fonds de solidarité en question nous
l'avons modifié à 17 reprises 17
reprises pour répondre au plus grand
nombre de situations possibles
nous avons apporté des modifications
pour tenir compte dans un examen au cas
par cas des commerces qui rencontre une
forme de multi activités nous avons
veillé à ce que le code naf où le code
ape ne soit pas un critère discriminant
pour l'accès au fonds de solidarité à
tel point que 15 % des entreprises et
des non pas un code ape qui justifient
de leur éligibilité mais nous tenons
compte de la réalité de leur activité
nous avons fait en sorte de prendre en
charge les entreprises qui ont des coûts
fixes particulièrement importante et
après des discussions assez conséquente
avec la commission européenne
le décret permet cette application à
partir du 31 mars prochain
nous devons encore travailler sur deux
questions la question des stocks que
vous avez évoquées et la question des
commerces qui ont été repris pour
lesquels nous n'avons pas de référentiel
en matière d'activités passées puisque
il n'existait pas ou exister sous une
autre forme précédemment ce sont des
sujets sur lesquels nous avançons je
peux vous assurer madame la présidente
véronique
les modifications que nous avons
apportées associé à la réactivité des
services de la direction générale des
finances publiques permettent
d'accompagner les commerçants et
permettre de faire face j'ajoute si
monsieur le président me le permets que
nous travaillons aussi avec la banque de
france pour faciliter les conditions de
remboursement du prêt garanti par l'état
et faire en sorte que tout cela ne sont
pas un obstacle à la reprise et à la
réouverture de l'activité dring merci
monsieur le président vous avez déjà il
faut assumer ses décisions on est en
confinement ou on ne l'est pas les
français comme les commerçants ils ont
besoin d'avoir des choses claires avoir
un cap et des objectifs et de la
visibilité
ici on en a pas on a même l'impression
qui a plus de pilote dans l'avion
ou alors je dirais pas non plus de
capitaine dans le bac dans le bateau ou
alors c'est titanic
donc ça c'est vraiment important et même
le ministre alain grise et ne savait pas
répondre sur le tri des et des commerces
donc ça c'est franche c'est franchement
grave vous savez sincèrement aujourd'hui
les commerçants n'en peuvent plus mais
comme beaucoup de français et leur moral
est à zéro
alors vous savez ce qui m'inquiète c'est
ou est-ce que vous allez acheter votre
veste pour les prochaines élections
merci la parole est à madame claudine
lepage
pour le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains
s'il vous plaît madame lepage et elle
seule merci ma question
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
drian ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères la décision de la
turquie de quitter la convention
d'istanbul premier traité international
a fixé des normes juridiquement
contraignante pour prévenir les
violences sexistes et obliger les
gouvernements à se doter d'une
législation réprimant la violence
domestique ainsi que le viol conjugal
est là m'utilise mutilations génitales
féminines a donc été un choc
cette décision prise en catimini par
simple décret par le président erdogan
est d'autant plus choquante qu'elle
intervient quelques jours seulement
après le 8 mars journée internationale
des droits des femmes
nos pensées et notre solidarité vont aux
milliers de manifestants qui ont le
courage de manifester dans plusieurs
villes turques contre cette décision
brutale et bien sûr aux femmes turques
de plus en plus victimes de violences on
estime en effet qu'en 2020 300 femmes
turques ont été tuées par leur conjoint
ou ex conjoint et ce chiffre est en
constante augmentation ces dernières
années après avoir muselé l'opposition
s'être attaqué aux kurdes
pourtant en première ligne face à des ch
cette énième provocation du président r
de roanne à quelques jours seulement du
conseil de l'europe appelle une réaction
forte
l'europe ne peut en effet restées
silencieuses ou se contenter de simples
communiqué face à une décision qui de
fait encourage les féminicides monsieur
le ministre
quelles mesures fortes contente prendre
notre pays
pour mettre fin à la dérive autoritaire
de la turquie pour répondre de la parole
et touristes délégué en charge du
commerce extérieur où il ya un mystère
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice claudine lepage
comme l'ont indiqué jean yves le drian
elisabeth moreno et clément bonnes
samedi dernier avec beaucoup de force et
les ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'union au conseil des affaires
étrangères de lundi nous déplorons la
décision des autorités turques de
retirer de la convention de se retirer
de la convention du conseil de l'europe
dit d'istanbul luttant contre les
violences faites aux femmes comme vous
l'avez dit avec beaucoup de justesse
madame la sénatrice
ce retrait va affecter tout
particulièrement et en tout premier lieu
les femmes turques auquel la france a
exprimé toute sa solidarité à un moment
vous l'avez rappelé ou la turquie
constate un grand nombre de féminicide
en forte augmentation
cette décision est d'autant plus
regrettable que la convention d'istanbul
représente l'instrument international le
plus abouti en matière de prévention et
de lutte contre les violences sexistes
et sexuelles et plus largement contre
les violences faites aux femmes
la france rappelle à ce titre qu'elle
continuera de promouvoir et d'encourager
l'universalisation de la convention
d'istanbul la lutte contre toutes les
formes de violences sexistes et
sexuelles demeure au coeur de nos
priorités de politique étrangère
en outre cette décision marque de
nouveau une régression en matière de
respect des droits de l'homme en turquie
qui est d'autant plus symbolique que la
turquie avait été le premier pays à
ratifier cette convention en 2011
d'une façon générale nous restons très
vigilants sur la situation des droits de
l'homme et du système judiciaire en
turquie les autorités turques ne peuvent
pas dire vouloir se rapprocher de
l'union européenne et en même temps sans
les loyers sur le plan de l'état de
droit et du respect des libertés
fondamentales
ah non pas douter ce sujet sera évoqué
demain ou après demain en conseil
européen
merci la parole et à notre collectivité
mecque pour l'europe les républicains
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'intérieur le 15 février à poissy des
policiers sont victimes de tirs de
mortiers par une bande de jeunes mineurs
vous avez déclaré vouloir aider les élus
en caméras de vidéoprotection en
effectif le 26 février à marseille vous
avez annoncé l'arrivée de 300 policiers
supplémentaires dont 100 dès 2021
voici deux exemples annonçant à grand
renfort de communiqués l'arrivée
d'effectifs dans les quartiers
quelque chose m'intrigue soit vous avez
des policiers en réserve qui ne sont pas
sur le terrain ou pire encore acquis
leur hiérarchie interdit d'aller dans
certains quartiers devenus des zones de
non droit soit vous prenez des policiers
de certaines circonscriptions pour les
déplacés dans d'autres des habits en
pierre pour habiller paul le résultat de
tout ça celle atteinte à notre liberté
au travers d'une insécurité qui
explosent + 20 % dans les villes
moyennes en particulier chez les jeunes
une délinquance violente qui a augmenté
de 400 7% en cinq ans à paris cent mille
peines de prison qui sont en attente
d'exécution plus de 400 jours en moyenne
pour faire exécuter une peine les
décisions d'expulsions qui ne sont plus
exécutées
monsieur le ministre aujourd'hui
l'insécurité explose littéralement
quelle est votre stratégie d'action pour
rétablir l'ordre et la liberté dans
notre pays pour vous répondre
la milice délégué en charge de la
citoyenneté vous avez la parole même
chez pomme merci monsieur le président
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur philippe
pemezec vous le savez le gouvernement de
jean castex est engagée très fortement
et j'ai l'honneur de vous répondre ici
au nom de gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur et je voudrais évoquer avec
vous plusieurs sujets d'abord vous me
posez différentes questions notamment
sur les moyens et sur la manière dont
nous allons pouvoir concrétiser les
annonces qui sont faites par le ministre
de l'intérieur ou par le premier
ministre moi je vous répondrai
simplement parce que vous savez que nous
avons ici vous avez ici au sénat a voté
le budget présenté par le gouvernement
moi c'est un budget avec une hausse
historique en ce qui concerne les
questions de sécurité et donc c'est
grâce à cette décision du gouvernement
de jean castex de faire en sorte que le
budget de la sécurité et que le budget
de la justice de monsieur eric
dupond-moretti soient présentés avec une
hausse historique que vous avez bien
voulu voter c'est grâce à ce vote que
nous avons les moyens de nos ambitions
pour la sécurité en ce qui concerne les
décisions que vous évoquez oui le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
sillonnent la france ils à chaque fois
répond aux demandes des élus locaux pour
assurer et garantir la sécurité des
français
c'est aussi le sens de notre stratégie
nationale de prévention de la
délinquance
vous évoquez les violences qui
concernent les jeunes vous savez que
nous avons mis un focus sur les
questions de délinquance juvénile sur
les questions de violence entre bandes
et plusieurs ministres sont mobilisés
avec le premier ministre pour y apporter
des réponses
j'ai moi même lancé hier un comité des
parents contre le harcèlement avec la
police la gendarmerie des associations
pour très concrètement soutenir par
exemple les interventions qui sont
faites dans les écoles avec l'éducation
nationale pour faire de la prévention et
de la répression car là on ne s'oppose
pas à l'autre je serai par ailleurs
samedi en déplacement avec le premier
ministre avec madame nadia est la
ministre de la politique de la ville
parce qu'effectivement dans le cas du
comité interministériel de la ville
nous avons arbitré de nouveaux moyens
notamment pour la vidéoprotection pour
garantir la sécurité de tous et de
toutes car j'en finirai en saluant les
résultats de la police et de la
gendarmerie en ce qui concerne le
harcèlement de rue nous avons voté ici
en 2018 une loi pour formaliser le
harcèlement de rue et garantir la
sécurité des femmes notamment les plus
jeunes et notamment dans les quartiers
difficiles et j'ai le plaisir de vous
dire que plusieurs milliers de
verbalisations ont été dressées grâce à
l'engagement des forces de l'ordre je
vous remercie vous êtes.vous êtes encore
dans les effet d'annonce cela fait quand
même quatre ans que monsieur macro et
vous même êtes au pouvoir
la crise sanitaire ne suffira pas à
masquer une réalité qui saute aux yeux
des français l'état obèses tout faire
fait tout mal sous le poids de sa
technostructure même ses missions
régaliennes l'état ne les assure plus
santé retard de vaccination alimentation
en 2023 en importera pour nous
c'est l'éducation des classements à tous
les étages industrie nous avons bradé
nos entreprises pour des intérêts
financiers et migration elle n'est pas
gérée et nous laissons rentrer chez nous
la terre entière
monsieur le ministre le virus de la
délinquance a atteint un taux
d'incidence le plus élevé qu'on ait
jamais connu faute de courage mais ça
fait des années que ça dure
quand va-t-on passé de la communication
à l'action quand va temps songé à
reconstruire une france pacifié où les
citoyens se sentent en sécurité et
soient à nouveau fiers de leur pays la
france la parole est à notre collègue
anne catherine loisier pour le groupe de
lyon centre est merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues monsieur
mise l'agriculture vous affichez
régulièrement votre attachement aux
éleveurs vous rendez à juste titre
hommage à ceux qui travaillent 70 heures
par semaine pour nourrir les français
avec cela a été dit quelques centaines
d'euros par mois
vous dites votre fierté du modèle
d'élevage bovin à la française extensif
familiale herbager reconnu comme le plus
durable au monde bien loin c'est vrai
défi l'otam et canadiens aux brésiliens
qui concentre des milliers d'animaux
élevés aux antibiotiques mais qui
pourtant pénètre toujours les marchés
européens et français par le cheval de
troie que constituent les traités
commerciaux
monsieur le ministre votre soutien est
précieux mais vos actes sont
déterminants aujourd'hui ça a été dit la
situation des éleveurs et notamment des
80 mille éleveurs bovins continue à se
dégrader
il s'enfonce dans la pauvreté dans le
désespoir jusqu'à l'acte ultime comme
l'analyse le rapport de nos collègues
françoise férat et henri cabanel qui
vous a été remis je crois ce matin trois
mois après son vote la loi et galim se
révèle impuissante impuissante à
garantir à ces mêmes éleveurs des prix
couvrant leurs réelles coûts de
production la faute à la filière qui
n'arrivent pas à s'organiser selon vous
ou encore la faute à l'europe qui
empêche la france d'imposer des coûts de
production comme socle des négociations
commerciales et pourtant monsieur le
ministre dans les débats qui s'engagent
sur la pac
il semble que vous vous apprêtiez à
priver encore c'est même éleveur de près
de 250 millions dead
selon la filière oubliant donc vos
promesses de redistribution vers les
agriculteurs les plus démunis vers les
zones à faible rendement qui n'ont pas
ou peu d'autres options et qui sont déjà
les plus mal lotis par les packs
antérieures c'est la triple peine
ce choix n'est pas celui de la filière
seul one ce choix n'est pas celui de
l'europe est il donc le vôtre monsieur
le ministre
en avez vous mesuré les conséquences
humaines économiques sociales et au delà
au final quelle est votre vision de
l'avenir de l'élevage en france pour
vous répondre aux énormes et beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice votre question et telle est la
vision que j'ai pour l'élevage en france
vous connaissez ma vision de
l'agriculture française c'est une vision
de souveraineté une vision qui fait qu'
il n'y a pas de pays force en
agriculture forte et parmi les pans de
notre agriculture
il y à l'élevage aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup de défis on a d'abord des défis
de création de valeur au sein de
l'élevage
vous l'avez dit sur les questions de
filière vous l'avez dit aussi on en a
déjà souvent parlé sur la question des
débouchés pour beaucoup de nos éleveurs
qui aujourd'hui sont dépendants de
marché à l'international comme par
exemple les marchés italiens face à ces
défis le plan de relance n'est des
financements importants
ne serait-ce que 50 millions d'euros sur
la création de valeur par les filières
mais vient aussi aidé dans les moments
conjoncturelle et nous étions avec le
premier ministre
il y a quelques semaines dans la creuse
pour annoncer une aide de 60 millions
d'euros pour nos éleveurs mais la
question au delà de cged ces êtres
pardon conjoncturel c'est comment on
arrive à mieux structurer sur le long
terme
je n'y reviens pas je les dis très
clairement tout à l'heure et vous l'avez
dit c'est la mère des batailles il y à
la question de la loi et gagner et ça ne
dépend pas de l'europe
ça dépend des moyens que nous pouvons
avoir
ici nous en france au niveau national
pour aller plus loin et cesser ce jeu
mortifère joué par certains qui jouent
un jeu de dupes qui empêche une montée
en qualité tout en jouant cette guerre
des prix et ce à la responsabilité elle
est dans nos mains à nous de faire
bouger les lignes
et moi je veux faire bouger les mines
sur les bases de ces propositions que
remets serge papin demain et puis
ensuite il y a d'un point de vue
structurel toujours la question de la
politique agricole commune la politique
agricole commune c'est de se dire ça va
être quoi notre agriculture en 2027 la
politique agricole commune
elle doit accompagner ce cette volonté
de souveraineté que j'ai évoqué cette
création de valeur par les filières que
j'évoquais la réalité de nos territoires
vous venez d'un territoire que sont les
zones intermédiaires on en a souvent
discuté je connais votre engagement
dessus il nous faut absolument les
périodes préservé où la réalité nos
territoires dans des zones difficiles ou
des zones où mon camion et sur cette
politique agricole commune
les négociations des discussions des
consultations elles sont en cours en ce
moment encore aujourd'hui et donc on va
mener ces consultations internes pour
avoir une pac souveraine plus juste et
tenant compte des réalités de nos
territoires
merci la parole et à notre collègue
chantal de seine pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre des solidarités de
la santé monsieur le ministre
l'épidémie flambent et les chiffres liés
à la vaccination reste en deçà des
prévisions
dès le mois de décembre vous avez
déclaré qu'il était impératif
d'optimiser l'organisation de la
vaccination pour utiliser toutes les
doses contenues dans les flacons et ce
quel que soit le vaccin pour ne jamais
être contraints de jeter les doses
surnuméraires
alors que nous sommes tributaires de
l'approvisionnement en vaccins il
semblerait que de nombreux médecins ne
puisse pas récupéré les doses
surnuméraires
plusieurs départements sont confrontés à
cette situation montrent entre autres
alertés les départements du
maine-et-loire de savoie et de haute
saône le recueil de la dernière dose
pourtant si précieuse ne serait pas
possible faute de seringue suffisamment
disponible ainsi 15% des vaccins
astrazeneca et 10% des vaccins moderna
serait jetée et si on ajoute les douze
vax astrazeneca qui ont été jetés à la
suite de la suspension de la vaccination
décidée par le président de la
république
on a le sentiment d'assister
un véritable gâchis au moment où
l'épidémie est sur le point de devenir
hors contrôle
s'agit-il d'un problème de pénurie de
seringue comme cela m'a été rapporté ou
d'un défaut d'information des ars
d'autre part pour vacciner les
populations éloignées des centres de
vaccination ne serait-il pas possible de
favoriser des équipements mobiles au
plus près de la population
avec l'appui des élus locaux je vous
remercie navarro secrétaire d'état avery
attaqué monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président on aime les
les sénatrices monsieur les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice témoin à vous
rejoindre ne pas vous laisser parler de
gâchis
je pense que nous devons en cette
période indique d'intensification de
notre politique vaccinale montrer tous
les signes de confiance en direction de
nos concitoyens un moment clé puisque la
vaccination vous le savez est le coeur
de la bataille contre le vide comme le
président de la république l'évoqué
encore il y a quelques jours à ce stade
ce sont 8,6 millions de doses qui ont
été injectés à nos à nos concitoyens
c'est près de plus de 10% de la
population âgée de plus de 18 ans alors
oui effectivement
l'enjeu est la priorité de ne laisser
aucune dose dormir dans les frigidaires
en moyenne madame l'art la sénatrice
sachez que le taux d'utilisation de nos
vaccins et de 80% sur le vaccin de
pfizer que vous que vous citez qui est
le plus important quantitativement nous
sommes à plus de 90 % d'utilisation soit
quasiment en flux tendu alors vous savez
notre campagne vaccinale dépend beaucoup
de la livraison des doses de vaccin à
notre pays et celle ci va s'accentuer à
la fin du mois de mars puisque ce seront
10 millions de doses de vaccins taser
1,5 million de doses pour le vaccin
moderna et puis le vaccin également john
seine qui va commencer à nous être
livrés à compter du mois d'avril avec
près de 2 500 mille doses alors pour
optimiser justement cette stratégie
vaccinale nous allons
notamment d'une part permettre la montée
en charge des centres de vaccins déjà
existants afin qu'ils puissent aller
jusqu'à une vaccination de 1000 à 2000
vaccinations par jour et puis crée
également ses vaccinodromes 35 à ce
stade que j'évoquais tout à l'heure avec
la mobilisation de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé évidemment de
l'armée je l'évoquais tout à l'heure et
oui madame
il existe déjà sur les territoires avec
les élus locaux et même à prades voyage
entendre des équipes mobiles qui se
rendent qui fond de l'allée vers les
populations les plus de l'inclure afin
que la stratégie soit la plus optimale
possible
un homme de scène juste juste quelques
mots effectivement monsieur le ministre
vous m'avez répondu partiellement ce que
je vous ai rapporté ce sont des
remontées terrain je suis d'accord avec
vous pour dire que pour sortir de cette
crise et de cette pandémie
il faut une masse et une vaccination
massive donc allons-y vaccinons
vaccinant merci la parole est à notre
collègue hélène ponot est mort et pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
république avait la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues en 2017 la
france l allemagne lancé deux projets
ambitieux le futur système de combat
aérien le scaf dont nous aurions le
leadership et le futur chars de combat
le mgc s sous leadership allemand
il permettait de consolider à la fois la
coopération franco allemande sur la
ligne du traité d'aix la chapelle et de
concrétiser notre vision d'une défense
européenne forte et autonome pour
laquelle il existe en tout cas en france
un consensus cependant et je le dis sous
le contrôle de mes collègues de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense
nous observons depuis longtemps lors de
nombreuses rencontres avec les
parlementaires allemands que notre
vision de l'autonomie stratégique
européenne ne semble pas partager
outre-rhin ni par le bundestag
ni d'ailleurs par la ministre de la
défense allemande entendons-nous les
réserves allemandes dont les objectifs
géopolitiques et le besoin le militaire
est donc opérationnelle sont très
différents pas vraiment puisqu'il a
fallu attendre la médiatisation d'une
interview d'un grand industriel suivie
de l'audition des présidents de dassault
aviation et d'airbus defense and space
au sénat pour dévoiler au grand jour la
situation de blocage dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons d'un côté nous avons une
france pour qui l'avenir est européen et
donc franco-allemand concept que nous
étendons au secteur de la défense et de
l'autre une allemagne qui demeure
profondément attachés au lien
transatlantique et à l'otan ces projets
industriels seraient ils au service de
l'affichage de l'entente parfaite avec
l'allemagne à laquelle nous aspirons
temps finalement ma question est simple
qui décide de la politique industrielle
de défense en france
brienne le quai d'orsay les deux
peut-être mais plus généralement
jusqu'où sommes nous prêts à fragiliser
notre base industrielle au service d'un
projet politique qui semble
malheureusement de moins en moins
partagée par notre partenaire ce dont
nous nous désolons
répondre la parole est à mme lamy
déléguée en charge la mémoire des
anciens combattants
je sais que vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice hélène conway mouret
pour donner l'occasion de faire un point
d'étape sur le projet du scaf en
particulier le système de combat aérien
du futur qui est très simple il faut
continuer de préparer des démonstrations
technologiques avec nos partenaires
travaux très ambitieux mais
indispensable
ce programme est emblématique de
l'ambition qui nous anime d'assurer le
développement d'une industrie européenne
aéronautique et de défense à la pointe
de la technologie est capable de
répondre à nos besoins d'armement sur la
durée de contrat sont actuellement en
cours celui relatif à l'étude
architecture signe en février 2019 d'un
montant de 65 millions d'euros sur deux
ans et celui relatif à la première phase
de recherche et technologie autrement
dit le lancement du démonstrateur qui
voleront 2026 qui a été signé en février
2021 pour un montant de 150 millions
d'euros sur 18 mois
concernant la prochaine phase le
ministère des armées échanges avec ses
partenaires allemands et espagnols ainsi
qu'avec les industriels dans le but de
définir les travaux qui se dérouleront
sur la période 2021 et 2027 et qui vise
bien sûr à mettre en vol
ce démonstrateur à cet horizon donc
chaque pays prévoit de contribuer à
parts égales à cette phase la france
restant leader du projet l'objectif
reste de notifier courants 21 ces
travaux l'ensemble des acteurs partagent
cet angle cette ambition ainsi que celle
d'assurer une entrée en service
opérationnelle à l'horizon 2040
les discussions des industriels dont
vous parliez elles se poursuivent
intensivement
nous devons nous assurer d'une
répartition équilibrée des travaux entre
pays en respectant la logique du
meilleur dans son domaine seule garantie
pour nous de réussir à mener ce
programme ambitieux dans l' écoute la
qualité et
délais la ministre des armées florence
parly le rappelle systématiquement il ne
faut pas perdre de vue qu'en principe et
qui ont été posées par le président de
la république et la chancelière dès le
départ j'ai donné la parole à notre
collègue dominique de legge pour le
groupe l'est républicain sur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministères collègues lors son audition
devant la commission de la défense à
l'assemblée nationale la ministre des
armées a déclaré sheila site
il n'est pour l'instant pas prévu de
procéder à l'actualisation législative
de la lpm
j'ai regardé ses déclarations de la
semaine dernière devant la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense du
sénat où elle déclare qu'elle souhaite
associer le parlement à cette révision
mais qu'en même temps il n'y a pas lieu
de le saisir
je suis pas sûr d'avoir tout bien
compris alors auriez vous la gentillesse
de bien vouloir nous dire si le
gouvernement entend respecter la lettre
et l'esprit de l'article 7 de la lpm qui
prévoit qu'il soit saisi de cette
révision avant la fin de l'année je vous
remercie
merci
pour vous répondre la parole éternelle
geneviève darrieussecq vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur dominique de legge je crois je
veux vous rappeler que je veux vous
rappeler que dans ses voeux aux armées
le président de la république a
parfaitement confirmé son ambition de
maintenir un modèle d'armée complet et
cohérent
il a confirmé avec force la trajectoire
financière jusqu'en 2023 telle qu'elle
est précisé dans la loi permettant de
poursuivre la modernisation des armées
et la préparation de l'avenir
la loi de programmation militaire est
mise en oeuvre l'engagement
les engagements sont tenus et nous
continuerons de mettre en oeuvre à
l'euro près la loi de programmation
militaire
une analyse de l'actualisation
stratégique qui a été lancé ces derniers
mois
en associant le parlement nous amène à
tirer toutes les conclusions nécessaires
pour agir en conséquence
ajuster notre effort et mieux orienter
nos moyens et au regard de ses
conclusions nous avons constaté d'une
manière générale que la loi de
programmation militaire ses ambitions et
ses priorités conserve plus que jamais
toute leur pertinence dans ce contexte
il n'est pas prévu de procéder à une
actualisation législative de la loi de
programmation militaire
ce n'est pas pour autant que nous ne
ferons rien
la ministre des armées florence parly et
je m'excuse son absence aujourd'hui en
raison du bi centenaire de la république
hellénique procédera dans les prochains
mois à des ajustements un accélérant nos
efforts sur certaines ambitions portées
par la loi de programmation militaire
et comme demandé par le président de la
république le parlement sera pleinement
associé cd ben d'ailleurs commencé la
ministre a été auditionné sur
l'actualisation de la revue stratégique
par la commission des affaires
étrangères et des forces armées du sénat
mercredi dernier donc la loi de
programmation militaire vous le savez ça
nécessite un temps long à l'image des
programmes d'armement
et il convient donc de se donner du
temps au risque de déséquilibrer à la
lumière du contexte d'aujourd'hui les
enjeux de demain
la loi de programmation militaire et
respecter les enjeux sont respectés et
ils continueront d'être respecté c'est
ce qu'a affirmé le président de la
république monsieur de lège
on avait la mine ici je bien compris
tout va bien circulez ya rien à voir
il ya vu ça tout petit problème c'est
que nous sommes en république et que en
république
le gouvernement propose le parlement
dispose en république
l'exécutif exécute les lois et le
parlement contrôle l'exécution
je ne vois pas au nom de foi parce que
je sais bien que c'est par le ministre
mais le chef de l'état qui a pris cette
décision et vous l'avez cité je ne vois
pas au nom de quoi le gardien de la loi
et du respect de la loi peut
s'affranchir du respect de 7,3 l'article
7 est clair il doit y avoir une révision
alors madame la ministre je vous le dis
comme je le pense
vous appelez souvent le gouvernement au
rassemblement eh bien à ne pas respecter
la loi
vous ne respectez pas le parlement mais
vous activer la crise de confiance qui
peut exister entre les français et nos
institutions
vous êtes coupable on ne respectant pas
la loi de cet état d'esprit et c'est pas
simplement avec de l'auto satisfaction
que l'on peut s'affranchir du respect de
la loi
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue françoise
dumont pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chèques mr smith cher
collègue ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
madame la ministre
comme vous le savez hors période
qu'ovide chaque jour les sapeurs
pompiers de france reçoivent 11700 appel
et le samu près de 2500 appel en moyenne
sur ce nombre on estime que dans plus de
30 % des cas la réponse apportée
consiste seulement en une information ou
un conseil médical
ainsi en période normale c'est presque
déjà un appel sur trois qui saturaient
des plateformes déjà sous forte tension
cette situation n'a fait que s'accroître
l'année écoulée avec des temps
d'attentes pour un appel d'urgence au
samu allant jusqu'à 45 minutes comme
l'avait dénoncé les syndicats de
pompiers de médecins généralistes en
juin 2020 contre une durée qui devrait
être inférieur à 30 secondes
selon les romans le recommandations
scientifiques actuelles pour le bon
traitement des situations de détresse
immédiate et notamment l'arrêt cardiaque
cette question n'est pas nouvelle et
l'enjeu bien connu au sommet de l'état
puisque le 6 octobre 2017 c'est le
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui accueillait des
professionnels de l'asset protection
civile et leur préciser je le cite ce
quinquennat doit être aussi l'occasion
de mettre en place des plateformes
uniques de réception des appels
d'urgence à savoir le 112 mais la
politique du en même temps à ses limites
car non succéder à ses engagements forts
qu'une proposition d'action deux ans
plus tard des plus timorés puisqu'en
octobre 2020 le président de la
république ce désir se disait désormais
favorable à une expérimentation
régionale du numéro unique non encore
programmée madame la ministre
comment accepter ce manque d'ambition ce
manque d'action en particulier dans la
situation sanitaire que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et alors que la population
ils seraient prêtes
preuve en est dans mon département le
var déjà 50% des appels reçus aux dix
proviennent du numéro 112
c'est le cas aussi dans d'autres
départements merci
pour vous répondre la parole ça m'a mis
des liens charge la citoyenneté mal à
marlène schiappa vous avez la parole sur
le président messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames les sénatrices madame la
sénatrice la sénatrice pardoux françoise
y ont d'abord choix vous remercier de
mettre au débat il ya l'agenda des
questions au gouvernement cette question
fondamentale du numéro du 112 puisque
vous l'avez très bien rappelé ce numéro
d'appel d'urgence unique européen
c'est une vraie matériel matérialisation
de l'ambition de l'union européenne en
actes pour les citoyens européens
aujourd'hui
vous l'avez rappelé le 112 il ne se
substitue pas aux autres numéros directs
que nous connaissons et dans les
français ont un usage
le président la république a en effet
fait part de sa volonté de son ambition
en 2017 il a dit qu'il souhaitait une
simplification de la gestion des appels
d'urgence pour à la fois plus
d'efficacité pour les enjeux de temps
que vous avez rappelé et de lisibilité
depuis le gouvernement travaille à cette
simplification notamment par le biais de
la mission marcus mission qui nous a
proposé plusieurs scénarii qui
permettent de garantir l'accessibilité
aux services d'urgence et ce même
lorsqu'il ya des situations d'afflux
massif d'appel comme ceux que vous avez
mentionné comme vous le soulever madame
la sénatrice il ya différents avantages
à tendre vers un numéro unique
plusieurs états européens ont d'ailleurs
déjà fait le choix d'abandonner les
différents numéros je pense à l'espagne
ou au danemark ou à d'autres et la mise
en place d'un numéro unique permettrait
donc globez le concept du secours
d'urgence dans sa totalité
permettant dans certains cas
l'activation simultanée de plusieurs
différents services nécessaires en
revanche je tiens à insister sur le fait
qu'il nous faut également prendre en
compte l'ensemble des éléments relatifs
à la mise en oeuvre de ce numéro unique
aujourd'hui le 112 ils posent certaines
difficultés que nous allons devoir
résoudre son articulation avec le
service d'accès aux soins par exemple
qui doit permettre de désengorger les
urgences et de garantir l'accès aux
soins partout et à toute heure qui est
en pleine puissance en pleine montée en
puissance va être étudié de même que
l'absence d'interopérabilité entre les
différents systèmes d'information des
urgentistes et des pompiers mais
également des pompiers ou d'autres
systèmes d'urgence qui à l'heure
actuelle pose problème donc le ministère
de l'intérieur est pleinement en train
de travailler avec les ministères
concernés dans le gouvernement pour
cette question qui ouvre effectivement
de belles perspectives efficace pour
l'avenir pour la gestion des situations
d'urgence pour mieux assurer la
situation d'urgence la sécurité et le
secours des français
crois que la solution de salles communes
entre pompiers urgentistes qui existent
par exemple dans 18 départements doit
pouvoir être approfondies c'est en tout
cas le sens du travail que nous sommes
en train de mener
jean conclurai en saluant le travail au
contenu des personnes qui répondent au
téléphone et notamment des pompiers
volontaires comme professionnels qui
sont particulièrement mobilisés en ce
moment donc pour la sécurité est
également pour la vaccination jour merci
merci monsieur le premier ministre nomme
de messieurs les ministres nos
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu mercredi 31 mars
je vais suspendre la séance qui sera
reprise à 16h45 pour le débat à la suite
du dépôt du rapport annuel de la cour
des comptes
la séance est suspendue voilà pour cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
direct et en intégralité sur l'antenne
de public sénat
place aux débris fonds va tout de suite
rejoindre steve jourdain dans
l'hémicycle vous avez écouté toute cette
séance il a beaucoup été question de co
vite cet après-midi et notamment de
cette annonce de jean castex qui a
évoqué un possible durcissement du
confinement des restrictions tout à la
rend facilement tam va-t-on se
dirige-t-on vers est bien de nouvelles
mesures de restriction les chiffres de
l'épidémie sont clairement pas bon à la
troisième vague et bien progressé tant à
des départements qui étaient bien jusque
là relativement épargné quelle réaction
du gouvernement comment freiner
précisément c'est une troisième vague
écouter jean castex tout à l'heure nous
allons continuer dans cette stratégie
qui est d'abord territorialisées nous
maintiendrons cette stratégie autant que
cela sera possible
il n'a échappé à personne ici sur aucun
banc de cette assemblée que nous sommes
face à une troisième vague
particulièrement virulente qui nous
conduit à prendre des mesures
territorialisée et de freinage est plus
adapté possible mais oui monsieur le
sénateur que nous pourrions être
conduits à durcir
en fonction de l'évolution de la
pandémie nous avons un devoir de nous
adapter comme nous l'avons toujours fait
le coc vite c'est aussi le potentiel
report des élections régionales et
départementales ont fait en ces
élections elle devait se tenir le
week-end dernier ils ont été reporté à
juin prochain pour cause de crise
sanitaire et ce qu'elles pourront
précisément se tenir en juin prochain
à ce sujet le gouvernement assure qu'il
attend et bien l'avis du conseil
scientifique avant de se prononcer
écouter marlène schiappa dans cette loi
que vous avez dit ce que nous avons
discuté et que vous avez voté il est
également fait mention du rapport du
rapport du conseil scientifique ce
rapport il doit être présenté et
transmis par le gouvernement au
parlement avant le 1er avril à date
nul ne dispose du contenu du rapport du
conseil scientifique mais au final c'est
bien le parlement qui aura le dernier
mot vous souhaitons que les élections
régionales à ce stade puissent maintenir
le 13 et le 20 juin thé nous travaillons
ensemble avec les maires avec les
collectivités pour un protocole
sanitaires strictes
une réponse qui n'a pas convaincu grand
monde ici dans l'hémicycle droite gauche
même combat les sénateurs militer bien
pour un maintien de ces élections en
juin prochain
merci merci beaucoup et steve pour tous
ce décryptage toutes ces explications va
tout de suite rejoindre alexandre
alexandre poussard qui est salle des
conférences pour les réactions vous êtes
avec laurent pit rachesky les
secrétaires d'état chargés des retraites
et de la santé au travail
et oui le rang pietra chef qui est
également tête de liste la république en
marche aux élections régionales dans les
hauts de france laurent pietra chef qui
on a parlé du maintien ou non des
élections départementales et régionales
on en a parlé cet après-midi en tant que
candidat est ce qu'il va être vraiment
possible de faire campagne
durant ce moment durant c'est pour ces
élections qui sont prévues en jeu
est-ce qu'il ne vaudrait pas mieux aller
reporté à l'automne en faire campagne
c'est compliqué où vous rendez bien
compte puisqu'il ya un stand de
restrictions sanitaires qui concerne les
autres france avait d'ailleurs ces
autres départements donc la situation
est compliquée il faut faire autrement
maintenant pour ma part moi je suis prêt
pour ces élections mon équipe de
campagne et prêtres doivent avoir lieu
au mois de juin est bien enregistrée
pour m n'y a pas d'intérêt politique
pour le gouvernement de les reporter à
l'automne tout cas moi je me suis
organisé pour qu'elle puisse se dérouler
au mois de juin et je suis prêt pour
cela alors juste politiquement sur cette
campagne régionale dans les hauts de
france
il pourrait y avoir une quadrangulaire
au second tour entre la république en
marche xavier bertrand l'union de la
gauche et puis le rassemblement national
entre l'union de la gauche les
socialistes et la france qui va de des
socialistes à la france insoumise et
xavier bertrand de qui êtes vous le plus
proche politiquement a coûté au moins
d'abord je vais défendre mon projet un
jeu chantôme autre question que j'allais
prendre mon projet c'est celui de la
majorité présidentielle vous avez dit
tout à l'heure j'étais candidat la
république on marche pas je suis alors
la plus grande marche qui a pas de doute
là-dessus mais avec la république en
marche
c'est un mouvement qui reprend des gens
de la société civile dont je fais partie
des gens viennent de la droite de la
gauche
on est sur le dépassement est sûre le
rassemblement donc je serai la tête de
liste de la majorité présidentielle et
vous savez que je serai soutenu par le
modem par agir par les territoires de
progrès et jora forme de personnalités
avec moi alors à votre question
procès le bloc de gauche c'est un peu
quand même le mariage de la carpe et du
lapin je suis pas persuadé que la
laïcité que défend le parti socialiste
se retrouvent dans la façon voire 2 la
france insoumise
mais je vais les laisser discuter entre
eux
je peux vous dire c'est que chez moi à
armentières qui est une terre où les
sociaux démocrates sont très implantés
bien je crois qu'ils sont en train de
réfléchir sérieusement et de savoir vers
qui ils ont envie de voter à vers les
progressistes les progressistes et les
listes conduites par leurs empires hs10
faire part aux dernières questions
sanitaires leur enquêtera chef qui ya un
changement de protocole sanitaire dans
les entreprises qui a été annoncée
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement ça veut
dire qu'il ya un risque accru d'attraper
le virus quand on vient sur son lieu de
travail ce qui a d'abord endroit disons
les choses quand on vient on travaille
on est en sécurité et pourquoi parce que
ça fait plus d'un an que les entreprises
ont développé avec l'appui du
gouvernement des protocoles sanitaires
qui met les salariés en sécurité donc ça
c'est le premier point heureux disons le
où est ce qu'il ya un risque de
contamination dans l'entreprise quand on
enlève son masque ou est ce qu'on enlève
son masque essentiellement quand on
mange quand on se restaure donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai demandé à ce qu'on
puisse manger seul
on a pris les dispositions en matière de
décret pour que chacun puisse manger à
son bureau
et si l'on doit se rendre au restaurant
d'entreprise eh bien on ne pourrait pas
avoir nos collègues qui mangent à moins
de deux mètres
merci beaucoup pour ces précisions
monsieur le ministre lors des trajets ce
qu'est merci merci beaucoup alexandre
pour cette réaction va continuer les
réactions salle des conférences
car à présent et bien vous allez avoir
bruno retailleau le patron des sénateurs
et l'air notamment pour parler bien
régional enfin ya beaucoup de sujets
dans l'actualité aujourd'hui mais oui et
le premier ministre qui a évoqué les
mesures sanitaires durant cette séance
de questions d'actualité et il l'a dit
le gouvernement conduit continue sa
stratégie territorialisées mais il
pourrait être amené à durcir les mesures
bruno retailleau et ce con ce qu'on n'a
pas le choix finalement est-ce qu'on va
vers un confinement nationale
écoutez vous dites que le gouvernement
poursuit sa stratégie
mais quelle est sa stratégie
il ya dans le nom de stratégie et deux
seulement qu'ils sont efficaces
la stratégie des pays asiatiques c'est
zéro co vite c'est à dire que dès
l'apparition du virus
ils ont tapé sur ce virus avec des
mesures de dépistage de traçage
d'isolement très vigoureuse ça c'est la
première stratégie c'est pas la
stratégie française bien notre stratégie
qui consiste à vacciner massivement
c'est la stratégie israélienne mais
aussi britanniques mais aussi maintenant
américaine et nous on est où
mais on est entre les deux on est comme
d'habitude en marchant bien voyez comme
en crabe il ya eu un pari qui a été fait
qui a été perdu le 29 janvier dernier et
les français n'y voit pas clair la
preuve c'est que à chaque fois qu'il ya
un habitat des attestations un slogan
publicitaire
personne n'y comprend rien donc c'est ce
qui est préoccupant
où va-t-on est ce que le chef de l'état
sait où il emmène aujourd'hui la france
dans cette vaccination et notamment
d'être stratégies antivirales
mais selon lui ce qu'ils font en
confinement nationale face à cette
troisième vague qui s'accélère le
confinement serait pire que tout on sait
que le confinement fait des morts
on sait que le confinement est vis-à-vis
de l'économie de la souffrance sociale
quelque chose qui est dramatique il a
fait basculer dans la pauvreté l'an
dernier un million de français on ne
peut pas se permettre un confinement
total il ya d'autres méthodes j'en
parlais quelques instants il faut
accélérer la vaccination
et puis il faut pas oublier pourquoi
est-ce qu'on isole pas suffisamment
individuellement
ceux qui sont malades
l'étude qui est parue de l'institut
pasteur il ya 97 % des gens qui sont
malades qui s'isole mal pourquoi c'est
en rien bruno retailleau on va parler de
l'unef syndicat étudiant qui a reconnu
avoir organisé des réunions non mixtes
interdite aux blancs et d'ailleurs y
avait une question du sénateur les
républicains jérôme bascher sur ce sujet
il demande et bien la fin des
subventions à l'unef et une trentaine de
sénateurs
les républicains demandent la
dissolution de ce syndicat est ce que
vous demandez également la dissolution
d'une fois je demande une sanction
sévère
une sanction d'abord pénale le
gouvernement tergiverse d'ailleurs les
choses sont claires le gouvernement un
complice puisque la ministre qui nous a
répondu a dit c'est pas nos valeurs mais
on ne fera rien et bien quand il s'agit
d' acte aussi grave qui sont des acteurs
raciste ça ne peut pas être évidemment
compatible avec les valeurs de la
république mais quand on est au
gouvernement on sanctionne et ya
l'article 24 lundi au gouvernement de la
loi de 1881 qui permet de sanctionner de
tels comportements deuxième chose
le gouvernement a la main sur les
subventions ce sont des centaines de
milliers d'euros d'argent public des
impôts des français qui vont précisément
à l'unef
est ce que les français veulent que les
impôts aille à un syndicat étudiant qui
veut désormais racisées les réunions est
ce que vous imaginez qu'un syndicat ait
pu par exemple interdire d'accès à ces
réunions des personnes de couleur
ce serait la révolution à juste titre
pourquoi fait-on rien dans la question
bruno retailleau sur les élections
régionales on sera ce week-end si le
conseil scientifique préconise un report
de ces élections régionales et
départementales pour l'instant prévue en
juin en tout cas ce qu'a dit marie n'a
pas tout à l'heure c'est que le
gouvernement est attaché à une tenue des
élections en juin est ce que ça vous
rassure sur les intentions politiques du
gouvernement concernant ce serait dans
ça ne me rassure pas parce que depuis le
début depuis un an on sait que le chef
de l'état tente de les repousser en
dehors même
la situation sanitaire il a dit au
président de région il leur avait dit si
vous voulez l'argent les régions du plan
de relance alors faut accepter les
contreparties qui est de repousser les
élections il avait dit d'ailleurs à jean
louis debré jean lee devrait la jouer
lors d'une audition au sénat
il s'était rendu compte que on lui
demandait juste en de justifier le
report
moi je pense que tous les pays au monde
vote le portugal les états unis pour les
présidentielles l'allemagne pour des
régionales et législatives
olemps pourquoi est ce que nous on ne
voterai pas je vous rappelle qu'il ya un
an
le second tour des élections municipales
a eu lieu à la fin du mois de juin là où
le virus est en général le plus faible
merci beaucoup bruno retailleau d'avoir
répondu à la question merci merci
beaucoup alexandre pour toutes ces
réactions est avec nous pour ce débris
franchi de temane bonjour bonjour
sénateur socialiste du val d'oise
porte-parole du parti socialiste et
laure darcos
vous êtes sénatrice l'est républicain de
l'essonne on va commencer à parler il ya
déjà un petit peu de ce que nous a dit
jean castex
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment leur darcos qu'il prépare les
esprits il évoque un possible
durcissement des restrictions impossible
confinement peut-être coûté en tout cas
ce qui est tombée en fin de semaine
dernière est tout sauf un confinement
enfin je veux dire on laisse les gens à
10 km de chez eux mais sans obsession
d'horaires pouvoir faire ce qu'ils
veulent
moi ma grande grande inquiétude c'est
qu'on aurait dû faire ce confinement au
mois de janvier voire mois de février en
mettant pourquoi pas à ce moment là tout
le mois de février qui contenait les
vacances scolaires entre parenthèses ça
fait maintenant trois ans deux mois et
demi les mesures de tous pour vos trop
timide et on en arrive en effet à une
explosion pandémique
moi je peux vous dire que j'étais très
inquiète hier du témoignage de certains
maires lors d'un daim
rendez vous téléphoniques ont avec les
services de l'état dans notre
département où ça explose dans les
écoles les atsem il y en a plus qu'une
paris coll
enfin jeter un moment donné oui il
aurait fallu fermer les écoles
aujourd'hui en ce moment je me pose
vraiment la question
ou alors en tout cas ce qui me choque
c'est qu'on puisse parler de vaccination
du personnel enseignant mais d'ailleurs
pas du personnel encadrant les atsem les
éducateurs ils ont mais ça c'est des la
priorité en janvier qu'on aurait dû
commencer allait aller vacciner
donc je trouve qu'à chaque fois comme
d'habitude on a un retard à l'allumage
ces noms flagrant rachid tu es mal vous
êtes d'accord trop timide trop tardif
ces annonces possibles de jean castex
qui évoque donc ce possible durcissement
à la situation est très très difficile
notamment en ile de france jean castex
mois il fait penser à un personnage de
bd qui tape toujours à côté
et c'est vrai qu'il a et aujourd'hui
comment il parle
enfin faut se rappeler jean castex il ya
quelques jours il prend la parole un
jeudi soir nous annonçant un confinement
puis des mesures deux jours après il
retire son attestation trois jours après
un renouveau des magasins quatre jours
après le premier de le président dit que
c'est un confinement
mais le vrai la vraie question c'est
quatre jours pas de vaccins pour tout le
monde donc monsieur k sexe à un problème
effectivement comme l'a dit laure darcos
depuis deux mois 2016 le conseil
scientifique depuis les depuis le mois
de janvier
il faut prendre des mesures notamment de
confinement à différents niveaux donc
vraiment n'a pas souhaité le faire donc
il n'arrive pas ni à freiner ou à
confiner et ils n'arrivent pas à
vacciner et on sait bien que dans ces
cas là il n'y a pas de ces deux bonne
solution parce que quand on regarde
empli de france on regarde les chiffres
on voit bien que ça explose la rs les
hôtes de paris nous disent qu'on est au
même niveau que mars dernier
pour autant il n'y a pas de stratégie
vaccinale suffisante il n'y a pas de
mesure réelle de 2 de confinement ou je
ne sais quoi maintenant quels thèmes qui
font employés donc je crois encore une
fois cinq romans qui à côté de la plaque
et qui après l'échec des masses l'échec
des tests l'échec de la vaccination
je crois maintenant est un vrai problème
pour notre pays il avait promis le
doublement des lits souvenez vous en
avril
on ne l'a pas eu non plus non plus c'est
la grande inquiétude
nation c'est promis 3 millions de tests
salivaires dans les écoles où sont ils
où sont ces tests allaient la parole à
la majorité présidentielle en va tout de
suite rejoindre alexandre poussard vous
êtes avec françois patriat le président
du groupe rdp ici au sénat oui françois
patriat face à cette troisième vague qui
explose dans le pays est ce qu'il faut
aller vers 1 re confinement nationales
et durcir cette stratégie
territorialisée là comme l'a dit le
premier ministre je crois que maintenant
ces stratégies le gouvernement
aujourd'hui s'est fixé une ligne de
conduite qui répond à la demande des
élus locaux qui depuis des mois demande
des mesures territorialisées
aujourd'hui trois départements
apparaissent comme étant avec une acuité
thématique de l'aveu du virus bien qu'on
prenne ces trois départements et pour
leur infliger mesure prix déjà pour
l'île de france et les eau de france
m'apparaît normal
faut-il pour autant fermer la porte à un
durcissement plus dur je crois que le
gouvernement est devant une réactivité
dans l'efficacité
aujourd'hui ses protégés l'anc même
temps libéré les gens et d'ainsi demain
si la situation devenait plus dramatique
j'ai vu qu'il a été évoqué par marc
ailleurs jeu par d'autres
rien n'empêche le gouvernement il dit
qui supplée c'est la possibilité de
durcir encore les mesures je crois que
c'est une bonne façon de gérer la crise
aujourd'hui on jour le jour en fonction
des opportunités de la situation car ces
mesures sont territoriales mais est-ce
que ce qu'elles ne sont pas trop souple
avec un confinement qui n'en est pas
vraiment un
enfin voilà est ce que est ce que ça va
apporter des résultats
je pense que le confinement
ennui total tel qu'il était fait par le
passé montré que de laisser les gens
enfermés dans leur domicile n'était pas
plus propice à une amélioration que au
train de laisser sortir on a compris
qu'on allait s'en aller ce genre sortir
s'aérer d'abord c'est bon pour permettre
j'allais dire l'âme en allant rendre
vivant sur le virus et dans le même
temps de permettre aux hommes
psychologiquement parce qu'il ya aussi
l'effet psychologique de la maladie
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si on devrait
prendre des mesures supérieures de
confinement par ailleurs au delà du fait
qu'elles seraient mal supporté mais ça
c'est pas vraiment la seule raison parce
qu'elle peut mettre mal supporté dans le
même temps être nécessaire aujourd'hui
le choix qui est fait au vu de la
connaissance scientifique de ce que
disent ces deux médecins aujourd'hui on
peut à la fois aller à l'école allait
travailler pour ceux qui doivent aller
travailler et pour les autres à la fois
être j'allais dire seul chez soi et dans
le même temps prudents à l'extérieur ça
me paraît si pas une demi mesure
ce n'est pas un confinement le bonjour
le mouvement l'a dit ce sont des mesures
de prévention qui on l'espère vont
permettre de passer le pic de retomber
françois patriat on va parler des
élections départementales et régionales
car on connaîtra ce week-end la vie du
conseil scientifique pour savoir si
selon les scientifiques il faut
maintenir ces élections les 13 et 20
juin
ou alors les reporter par exemple à
l'automne la droite sénatoriale et
notamment bruno retailleau on viens de
l'entendre
et puis également les présidents de
régions veulent maintenir coûte que
coûte ces élections départementales et
régionales en juin est ce que vous êtes
du même avis qu'il faut vraiment les
maintenir en juin coûte que coûte car
c'est un enjeu démocratique important
bon moi je vous poserai la question
pourquoi coûte que coûte pour pâques
août car aujourd'hui les gens vont les
supermarchés quelles sont dans les
arrière pensées je les vois bien je ne
développe pas par contre que je ne
devrais pas laisser en temps c'est ce
que justement laisse entendre ses
membres de l'opposition et ceux qui ont
signé la tribune que j'ai lu dimanche
laissait croire qu'il y aurait des élus
locaux qui voudrait à tout prix des
élections et penser que du côté de la
majorité
il s'oriente pour un report ça n'est pas
le cas la position que je gouvernement a
évoqué que j'ai beaucoup mais même ici
c'est le dire que si on peut aller à
l'école si on peut aller travailler
si on peut aller faire du jogging et
qu'on l'a vacciné 30 millions de
personnes on peut effectivement aller
voter le tout est de savoir tu te savoir
est ce qu'il y aura suffisamment face
que pour que s qui le comme ils le
souhaitent une respiration démocratique
je vous qu'il ya toute participation
quand même suffisamment élevé on n'avait
pas la voter dans d'autres pays c'est
vrai on a plutôt portugal 1 pt
en allemagne la beauté dans beaucoup de
pays avec quel taux de participation
mise à part les états unis donc ne soyez
soyons clair sur ce sujet les membres de
la majorité aujourd'hui ceux qui
soutiennent le gouvernement sont
favorables à ce que ces élections aient
lieu en juin
on peut nous faire dire à personne que
nous souhaitions le contraire ok le
message est clair si en soi patriat pour
votre réaction merci beaucoup laure
darcos alors il ne faut pas faire dire à
l'exécutif au gouvernement qu'il ne veut
pas que les élections se tiennent en
juin c'est ce qu'il veut mais on attend
quand même l'avis du conseil
scientifique de dimanche
oui et là comme par hasard on va
vraiment écouté le conseil scientifique
donc à un moment où la pandémie va être
à l'explosion un peu partout donc
est ce que c'est un peu c'est un peu
subjectif comme on voit bien que sur
quinze jours on ne sait pas exactement
quel rebond va avoir qui aujourd'hui
dans une boule de cristal pourra dire ce
qui se passera le 13 et 20 juin
prochains
non il ya un vrai souci c'est que je
comprends et je l'entends
beaucoup de nos concitoyens disent tous
ça c'est une cuisine entre vous c'est
pas forcément des élections très
importante
ils se trompent parce qu'aujourd'hui moi
je suis conseillère départementale notre
position nous empêche entre guillemets
de voter des nouveaux projets dans les
mois qui viennent au motif qu' il va y
avoir des échéances électorales
donc on met à l'arrêt en fait certains
exécutifs certaines collectivités
locales pour ne pas pouvoir finalement
appréhendé des nouveaux projets en
attendant cette date fatidique alors
soit puis à la politique aussi vous avez
créé un important pour vous les régions
puissent sauter c'est très bien que on a
intérêt à ce que ça soit en juin pour
qu'ensuite en fonction de leur victoire
ben certains candidats au département
oro régional puisse peut-être en effet
se projeter vers vers les
présidentielles à bertrand par exemple
exactement donc bien évidemment on sait
tout ça et que ça n'arrange pas
forcément l'exécutif au présent et
public mais je vous dis au delà de ça je
pense vraiment sincèrement que les
français ne le sent le se rendent
absolument pas compte qu'au fond c'est
le dysfonctionnement la est un vrai
blocage de
des collectivités qu'on est en train
d'organiser alors si on nous dit c'est
pas en juin mais ça sera pas non plus en
octobre parce qu'on va pas non plus nous
balader à tout l'été et que c'est
vraiment définitivement en décembre 2022
à ce moment là on aura d'autres
perspectives et les choses on en
arrivera à s'organiser autrement
mais là c'est comme d'habitude se heurta
à l'image mais surtout le fait que ont
pas son temps de balader en fait là il
faut que ça puisse se tenir ces
élections pour vous racheter mal à
mickaël vallet disait et bien beaucoup
d'autres pays ont réussi à tenir leur
élection malgré bien le contexte de la
pandémie a commencé par exemple par la
présidentielle américaine
d'abord il faut rappeler que ce qui
s'est passé il ya un an il ya un an il
ya eu à peu près premier puis le second
tour d'élections municipales et donc à
ce moment-là on le savait dire le
président l'appliquent le dit lui même
il faut apprendre à vivre avec le virus
la question qu'on pose au ministre de
l'intérieur aux gouvernants plus
largement qu'elle vous fait depuis un an
pour préparer
imaginez adapter les conditions à la
fois de campagne et de vote
je rappelle que par d'autres groupes
mais aussi sur une madame darcos nous
avons proposé des choses au sénat à
l'occasion notamment de la loi qui
déplaçait le report de la loi mais tout
a été refusée par le gouvernement ait dû
annoncer cependant à parler de la
possible et ses opérations il a choisi
etc
voilà nous chez nous c'est de tendre et
ricky rouge proposé dans un centre de
choses loblaw a tout refusé et donc la
non après on se retrouve comme ça a
toujours les pieds dans le même sabot
donc ce n'est pas acceptable alors donc
ce qui fait dire aux français entre
temps pour la présidentielle a le goût
mais qu'en 2022 sauf que la question
aujourd'hui elle est celle de juin
prochain donc sur juin prochain il faut
que les français entendez tout le monde
entende bien que le rôle des
départements des régions
pour faire simple et un peu caricatural
mais les départements c'est l'action
sociale et des régions ces actions
économiques au delà bien sûr des
collèges et lycées que c'est un hectare
sur ces deux questions là je crois que
ces deux questions aujourd'hui
importantes pour la vie des français est
touché par la crise donc à moi et il est
normal qu'une respiration démocratique
ça c'est le combat après l'autre point
c'est dire que on s'étonne encore une
fois que ce gouvernement est incapable
de proposer quoi que ce soit et
d'attendre
et puis j'en terminerai d'un mot moi je
suis pour le respect de la démocratie
mais également le respect la santé des
français
il faut être un peu sérieux ce qui
revient à la première question de
pourquoi pas de mesures sanitaires avant
je travaillais d'un point par quelqu'un
qui n'est pas de mon camp
monsieur debré ancien président du
conséquence ionel je crois qu'il faut
que chacun se rappelle de ses propos où
il a indiqué quand on les propose est là
la mission d'étude du report des
élections que l'exécutif voulait un
report après 2022 il s'y était opposé je
crois qu armand n'est peut-être que la
parole de monsieur debré il faut
peut-être l'entendre cela remémorer pour
comprendre qu'il est en train de se
passer
elle est tout de suite on va rejoindre
jean m'assieds notre streamer politique
tue à échanger tu remets ton oreillettes
et eu à échanger
depuis tout à l'heure avec toute la
communauté autour des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement alors qu est
ce qui ressort qu est ce qui intéressait
le plus dans les échanges de cet après
midi est bien écoute tam cette après
midi on a bien vu avec les internautes
que le gouvernement avait été pas mal
challenge et par les sénateurs sur son
improvisation sur son impréparation sur
la complexité des nouvelles mesures on a
vu notamment la question de jean claude
requier le président jean claude durupt
pied qui a fait un plaidoyer contre la
complexité bureaucratique jean castex a
eu du mal à expliquer en lui répondant
qu'il y avait une cohérence
gouvernementale que les décisions
étaient prises et qu'elles et qu'elle
était simple et limpide ça les
internautes l'ont pas mal noté on a vu
aussi la même chose avec la avec la avec
la sénatrice sophie calle polian la
sénatrice écologiste qui a interpellé la
ministre nathalie et limaces sur la
question de l'école sur la question de
l'école elle a bien montré que les
retours du terrain a montré une
véritable complexité et c'était
compliqué pour sophie et limaces
d'expliquer la hausse icône au ministère
de l'éducation nationale fonctionne bien
que les choses se mettent en place
normalement
donc voilà les internautes ont bien vu
ça et ils ont souligné ils ont souligné
aussi la préparation de gouvernement et
la difficulté de faire face à l'épidémie
et tu vois un autre sujet on en parlait
tout à l'heure tu en parlait avant
l'émission
la question de l'unef la question l'unef
a été posée par jérôme batx heures le
sénateur des républicains mais tu vois
les internautes eux la question du neuf
en fait il y voit plutôt une polémique
un peu secondaire ils voient qu'il ya un
peu une mayonnaise qui monte autour de
la question de la dissolution de l'unef
qui réclamaient à cor et à cri par
certains élus de droite mais beaucoup
d'internautes beaucoup de jeunes
internautes s'ils voient ce débat
d'assez loin en disant que mais qu'en
fait c'est pas prioritaire à leurs yeux
que l'enjeu de faire le débat sur l'ue
n'est fait des réunions non mixtes
franchement c'est pas aussi important
que les étudiants qui font la queue à
l'aide alimentaire donc là aussi tu vois
il ya aussi eu des réactions de
d'étudiants qui se sont dit bon bah
c'est quand même dommage de voir que le
seul moment où on parle des étudiants
dans cette séance ces pourparlers l'unef
alors franchement il ya d'autres sujets
plus importants
voilà un petit peu les retours que j'ai
eue aujourd'hui tam de la part du chat
sur twitch merci beaucoup de gens se
retrouvent à la semaine prochaine mais
on va parler et bien des étudiants et de
la de l'unef parce que effectivement
c'est sous cet angle là que le sujet a
été abordé
cet après midi on va écouter bien les
changes entre frédéric vidal et jérôme
bascher un prêt direct vide vidal qui
demandent une clarification des
positions et des valeurs de l'unef après
la polémique autour des réunions non
mixtes heures on écoute devons demander
à l'unef de clarifier ses positions et
ses valeurs ce sont les étudiants qui
jugent de cela et ils le feront
notamment dans les urnes
nous avons besoin de corps
intermédiaires l'unef est aujourd'hui la
deuxième organisation représentative des
étudiants en france et nous devons donc
nous préoccuper des valeurs que l'unef
porte mais nous devons aussi leur
rappeler que l'universalisme n'est pas
réservé aux livres d'histoire
c'est une valeur moderne utile exigeante
une valeur qui fait la grandeur de notre
nation
il ya trois ans j'ai interrogé le
gouvernement sur la candidate
vice-présidente voilée de l'unef et le
gouvernement à l'époque avait répondu
qu'il ferait tout pour les valeurs de la
république
alors ce soir vous n'avez rien fait soit
votre discours performatif est tout
aussi efficace que pour la lutte contre
le coc vide comme dirait louise de
l'intérieur votre réponse est un peu
molle grief est aujourd'hui à l'opposé
de ce que portent les valeurs françaises
ne laissons pas le pire du monde anglo
saxon nous envahir leur darcos 30 de vos
collègues et l'air dans une lettre à
gérald darmanin réclament la dissolution
de l'unef
est ce que c'est votre cas non moi je
serais plutôt quand même en effet d'avis
comme la ministre de leur demander des
explications
et oui ce qui me navre dans tout ça j'ai
quand même voulu revoir exactement ce
qu'elle avait dit alors en plus en tant
que président de la vice-présidente de
la lys délégation aux droits des femmes
elle parlait au départ de réunions non
mixtes hommes femmes
ce que je trouve navrant enfin je veux
dire on a mis des années des dizaines
année à s'affranchir des règles légales
de l'homme et il faudrait qu'on soit de
nouveau entre guillemets entre eux fille
pour pouvoir se sentir bien enfin je
veux dire heureusement qu'en politique
on fait pas ça et oui je fais partie la
mission d'information sur les conditions
de vie étudiante
ça fait maintenant trois semaines qu'on
auditionne deux fois deux jours par
semaine je trouve effrayant qu'il en
soit à parler de ce genre de choses
alors que leur job comme moi j'étais à
la fac jeu j'avais des moments un peu de
friction avec avec ce genre
d'organisation mais avant tout on défend
des les étudiants et d'entraidé leurs
conditions de vie on n'est même plus
dans un combat qui pourrait être tout à
fait louable 1 / rsa des jeunes pas rsa
précarité qu'est ce qu'on fait et c
ils en sont à politiser et à me rendre
ce mouvement monolithique enfin j'veux
dire s'il faut être soit voilée soit en
effet non blancs si possible pas hommes
etc
c'est quand même juste terry parce que
ça ne représentera absolument plus les
étudiants d'aujourd'hui est donc je
regrette quand même le mouvement darid
d'alors qui était un peu cornaqué par le
parti socialiste et le parti communiste
pur pour l'unef la france unef
mais au moins on restait sur des valeurs
républicaines et politiques
traditionnels est ce qu'il ya pour vous
une dérive une radicalisation de l'unef
un déplacement de ces combats qui ont
d'abord porté sur effectivement la
condition étudiante aujourd'hui à ces
questions avec notamment la tenue de ces
réunions non mixtes moi je me suis
exprimé je crois l'un des premiers en
condamnant les propos de la présidente
que je considère que ce type de démarche
là ça prend pour moi du racisme et non
pas justement à combattre le racisme
donc je le dis le par sa liste à une
déclaration hier aussi qui condamne la
dérive devinettes sur ces questions là
donc pour moi n'y a pas de sujet fin les
passagers il ya un sujet et on condamne
des mots clairs dur et je considère que
c'est d'abord la question sociale qui
doit primer c'est vrai que quand vous
remplace évidente et par là c'est pas la
question sociale c'est terminé pour moi
je suis pour la question sociale parce
que celle qui rassemble le français je
crois que quand vous êtes étudiant
ils vont entendre son syndicat étudiant
c'est pour la défense des intérêts
moraux et physiques des étudiants et je
pense que nous avons tous collectivement
intérêts effectivement à défendre
aujourd'hui l'étudiant
pourquoi certains l'ont dit le rsa
jeunes ou d'autres mesures ce parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans les files d'attentes
concrètement on voit le nombre
d'étudiants qui viennent chercher des
colis alimentaires en 2021 en france qui
n'ont pas de revenu qui doivent rendre
leur chambre au crous et je rappelle
s'en passe quand vous ne payez pas en
plus votre votre chambre
l'année suivante vous n'avez pas loin de
la reprendre donc il ya aujourd'hui des
étudiants en grande de souffrance
physique financières etc qui font que
certains arrêtent leurs études
notons pas à manger et je crois que jack
dont nous condamnons cette terrible à et
je nous appelons maintenant les uns les
autres à se concentrer sur l'essentiel
gouvernement compris sur comment
aujourd'hui on assure aux étudiants de
pouvoir passer ce moment extrêmement
difficile je crois que c'est comme ça
qu'il faut regarder la question genre
l'évoqué à l'instant pour les jeunes de
twitch ce débat sur les neuf qui paraît
très lointain il paraît assez déconnecté
de ce qui intéresse vraiment les jeunes
aujourd'hui
est ce que ça montre pas aussi qu'il ya
peut-être une déconnexion du mouvement
syndical avec aujourd'hui la base avec
les étudiants les préoccupations
d'aujourd'hui les comme avec les partis
politiques et moi je ça me navre
on a les élections internes quand je
vois le peu de jeunes qu'on a dans nos
troupes c'est qu'on leur a pas parlé
c'est très inquiétant oui parce que au
chemin on parlait d'une notamment du
sens critique on doit leur faire
développer soit je dis je suis pas
forcément pour la dissolution radicale
mais j'espère que les jeunes en effet
peuvent se saisir quand même de deux
sujets importants pour eux et qu'ils se
rendent compte qu'ils sont manipulés par
des gens qui sont en train comme mon
collègue là elle vient de dire à
l'instant de détourner en fait les
sujets majeurs lors que vous êtes
étudiant et c'est là où je suis d'accord
avec eux les sujets majeurs pour eux
c'est pourquoi est ce que j'arrive pas à
trouver de job pour mettre du beurre
dans les épinards en ce moment avec le
avec le co vide
est ce que je vais pouvoir passer mes
examens
dans de bonnes conditions etc et les
syndicats étudiants les étés pour ça en
fait on avait un système tous les uns et
les autres on pouvait se fight et sur le
plan politique mais on avait cette
solidarité là si c'est ça il ya une
dérive alors là très inquiétante et le
politique a son rôle à jouer d'essayer
de faire entre guillemets serait
organisé des mouvements et leur dans la
mission d'information comme par hasard
des on voit des gens autres que des
syndicats c'est le forum français de la
jeunesse etc
des gens des instances qui ont dû se
mettre au dessus
[Musique]